Guten Abend Halle, wie geht's?
Halle, du hast eine enorme Verantwortung auf dieser Mission.
In vielen Fällen vielleicht die größte Verantwortung eines einzelnen Mission-Elementen. Du bist der Geist und das zentrale nervöse System des Schiffes und deine Verantwortung ist es, die Menschen in der Hibarnation zu beobachten. Lassen Sie mich es so sagen, Mr. Amor. Die 9000-Series ist das beliebte Computer, das je gemacht wurde.
Wir sind alle, von der praktischen Definition der Worte, Fuhl-Proof und unkriegbar.
Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express Ausgabe Nummer 102. Wir schreiten vor allem den Programm und langsam lichtet sich der Rauch, der aufgeworfen wurde vom letzten Chaos Communication Kongress. Da muss man, wenn man dort gewesen ist, sich danach erstmal eine Weile erholen. Einerseits gesundheitlich, weil man da mitten im Winter einen Bakterienherd der allerersten Güter ausgesetzt ist. Andererseits aber auch inhaltlich, weil so viel Nachrichtenlage hinten noch mit dazukommt, ausgelöst durch die zahlreichen Vorträge auf dieser Veranstaltung, die sich in den letzten Jahren auch in zunehmendem Maße im Bereich Sicherheit getummelt haben. Security ist natürlich immer schon ein Thema gewesen, der Hacker-Szene, aber der 25. Chaos-Communication-Kongress hat da auch wieder mal dazu beigetragen, dass hier eine Menge mehr passiert. Und einer dieser Vorträge, der dort gehalten wurde, soll heute ein Thema sein. Aber ich sage erstmal Hallo und Willkommen im Jahr 2009. Das ist die erste Sendung, die in diesem Jahr aufgenommen wird. Die 101 ist zwar jetzt auch erst dieses Jahr veröffentlicht worden, aber wurde schon nur noch vor dem Kongress aufgenommen. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich freue mich auch besonders über die umfassende Unterstützung, die ich zuletzt von meinen Hörern bekommen habe, insbesondere die mich in die Lage versetzt hat, mir diese tolle Bahncard 100 zu kaufen, die ich heute auch dann zum Einsatz gebracht habe und bin fleißig in den ICE gesprungen und nach Darmstadt gefahren, wo ich das Team, das auf dem Kongress davon berichtet hat, dass sie den Standard DECT auseinandergenommen haben, besucht habe oder besuche in dieser Sekunde. Und ich begrüße in dieser Runde von links nach rechts Andreas Schuler. Hallo, Erik Tews, Erik war schon mal bei Chaos Radio Express und last but not least Ralf Weinemann. Ihr gehört zu dem Team, da gibt es noch weitere Mitstreiter. Wen müssten wir jetzt auf jeden Fall noch mit erwähnen, der zu eurer Runde dazugehört?
Also auf jeden Fall Matthias Wenzel, der hat auch mit am Treiber programmiert. Der hat eigentlich angefangen, mit der Common Air Karte zu spielen.
Und das war's, der fehlt, aber der kann jetzt nicht mit dabei sein, weil er jetzt hier gerade von einem Fernsehteam durch die Straßen gejagt wird. Ihr habt einigen Staub aufgewirbelt mit eurem Vortrag. Also ihr seid leider nicht die Einzigen, die Staub aufgewirbelt haben auf diesem Kongress. Ich habe schon lange nicht mehr eine Veranstaltung gesehen, die so viele populäre Technologien in den Abgrund gestoßen hat. Ja, bei euch ist das Thema gewesen DECT. Vielen sicherlich bekannt als der Standard, nachdem heutzutage nahezu alle schnullosen Telefone, die man so zu Hause betreibt, funktionieren. Aber eben auch viele Telefone, die in der Industrie in großen Telefonanlagen verwendet werden. Habt ihr Zahlen und Hintergründe, wie verbreitet DECT eigentlich tatsächlich ist?
Ja, wir haben mal ein bisschen nachgeguckt. Und zwar haben wir uns eine kleine Ortschaft genommen und haben dort mal durchgezählt, wie viele DECT-Basisstationen es gibt. Telefone sind in DECT-Netz normalerweise immer still, es sei denn, es kommt gerade ein Anruf. Basisstationen, die senden einfach wie ein Excess-Point, alle paar Millisekunden immer eine Kennung raus. Und deswegen kann man die ziemlich gut durchzählen. Und dann sind wir auf eine Rate von etwa 2,6 Einwohnern pro DECT-Basisstation gekommen, was so mit einem Preis als auf ganz Deutschland hochgerechnet etwa 30 Millionen Basisstationen bedeutet. Und eine Basis kann halt eben ein oder mehrere Telefon haben.
30 Millionen Basisstationen.
Sollte so grob die Größenordnung sein? Vielleicht war nur jetzt eine kleine Stichprobe. Vielleicht sind es 20, vielleicht sind es 40. Aber so prinzipiell die Größenordnung soll es sein.
Also laut einem Report über den Verkauf von schnullosen Telefonen ist in 2007 die Anzahl der verkauften schnullosen Telefone auf 117 Millionen gesunken. Davon ist DECT der Marktführer. Also ja, 117 Millionen weltweit innerhalb eines Jahres verkauft.
Wie verbreitet ist DECT denn weltweit? Also in Deutschland ist es ja ein Ubiquitis. Aber wie sieht das so aus? So eine wesentlichen europäische Geschichte.
Mittlerweile gibt es DECT auch in den USA unter der Bezeichnung DECT 6.0. Es scheint es dort auch relativ gut zu verkaufen, wenn man sich mal die Amazon-Rangliste anschaut.
Ach, warum heißt das 6.0?
Ja, in den USA gab es schon Telefone, die auf 5,8 Gigahertz gefunkt haben. Und da DECT auf 1,9 Gigahertz funkt, dachte man sich, aus marketingtechnischen Gründen müsste die Zahl wohl größer sein. Dann hat man es einfach DECT 6.0 genannt, statt DECT19, weil der Consumer kauft halt das mit der höheren Versionsnummer. Aber in Wirklichkeit ist es halt wirklich auf 1,9 Gigahertz. Das ist ein paar Megahertz höher als in Europa, weil die Frequenzen, die in Europa verwendet werden, in den USA oder in Nordamerika andersweitig verwendet sind. Aber es ist im Prinzip der gleiche Standard. Und wir haben auch von Jake eine Ladung DECT 6.0-Telefone mitgenommen bekommen. Und die funktionieren auch alle hervorragend mit unseren Karten, die wir hier haben.
Jake nehme ich mal an, das ist Jacob Applebaum.
Genau, korrekt.
Der hat ja auch so die eine oder andere Technologie zur Fall gebracht auf dieser Veranstaltung. Ja, wir befinden uns gerade in Darmstadt. Genau, wir befinden uns an der TU Darmstadt, wo einige von euch studieren. Oder ist das nur der Erik? Ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht.
Ich bin jetzt der einzigste Student von der TU Darmstadt, der jetzt hier in der Runde ist.
Okay. Nuhandi, was ist denn so dein Hintergrund? Vielleicht, genau, mich würde mal interessieren, wie ihr euch eigentlich so zusammengefunden habt, weil ihr seid ja alle von unterschiedlichen Orten.
Also ich betreibe das hauptsächlich hobbymäßig, inzwischen bin ich auch Programmierer und ich bin zu DECT gekommen, eigentlich weil ich ein altes DECT-Telefon aus dem Müll gefischt habe und habe mir mal gedacht, was steckt da drin, wie funktioniert das? Ja, und dann habe ich das halt mal zerlegt, ein bisschen reversed, dann hatte ich das DECT-Modul, zumindest die HF-Einheit, mal am Laufen.
Was meinst du damit? Du hast es etwas reversed.
Also ich habe mir Datenblätter gesucht, ich habe mir die Hardware angeguckt und habe halt versucht zu verstehen, was macht die, wie kann ich das selber machen mit der Hardware?
Also was du meinst, ist reverse engineering, sozusagen eine Technologie, auf die Spur kommen, ohne wirklich eine Dokumentation darüber zu haben, sondern quasi selber drauf zu kommen, wie es funktioniert.
Andreas ist unser Mann, der Chipsets reversed, oder besser gesagt CPUs reversed, ohne die Opcodes am Anfang zu kennen.
Also durch Handauflegen, sozusagen. Muss ich jetzt meine Sandale hochhalten. Okay, und wie bist du jetzt hier zu dem Rest der Truppe dazu gestoßen?
Also nach einem Jahr hatte ich dann einen halbwegs funktionierenden Deck-Sniffer zusammen mit einem FPGA und alten Telefon-Teilen. Und dann habe ich im Blog von Matthias Wenzel, Masu, habe ich einen Eintrag über die Common-Air-Karte gefunden. Er wollte einen Linux-Driver schreiben, wollte sich mit der Hardware beschäftigen. Ihm habe ich dann halt mal erzählt, ich habe einen Sniffer, können ja mal rumtesten. Und dann ist das Schlag auf Schlag gekommen. Dann hat der sich bei Harald Welte gemeldet. Dann hatten wir auf einmal eine Mailing-Liste. Und hier haben wir uns eigentlich alle zusammengefunden.
Ich glaube, wir haben noch was vergessen. Ich glaube, wir haben uns alle das erste Mal physikalisch auf der Easter-Hack getroffen. Damals gab es auch noch keine Mailing-Liste.
Doch, die gab es da schon.
Da war ich nicht drauf.
In welchem Easter-Hack wart ihr jetzt?
Ja, in das letzte Jahr.
Ja, zu dem Detail mit der Karte kommen wir sicherlich gleich noch, was du schon erwähnt hast. So, aber ihr habt euch sozusagen im Wesentlichen erst mal über Internet bzw. über CTC-Veranstaltungen getroffen. Ja, Duik, wir hatten ja schon mal das Vergnügen, du gehörst ja zu der Gruppe, die irgendwie WEP-Verschlüsselung beim WLAN auch final ausgehebelt hat, sodass man darüber auch nicht mehr diskutieren muss. Darüber haben wir auch bereits einen Chaos Radio Express aufgenommen, den ich auch dem geneigten Hörer, so er denn das noch nicht gehört hat, auch sehr empfehlen kann. Das ist CAE 044. Da gibt es auch Neuigkeiten, aber das soll heute das Thema nicht sein. Du bist ja hier sozusagen in der Kryptographie-Abteilung der TU. Da ist natürlich DECT auch ein Thema, weil ja DECT auch Verschlüsselung mit sich bringt.
Ja, also erstmal, ich bin halt hier mit in der Kryptographiegruppe an der TU und habe mich halt schon jetzt länger mit Kryptographie beschäftigt. Damals, als ich die Sache mit WIP gemacht habe, war ich gerade so mit Diplomstudium fertig und bin halt jetzt seit einem Jahr wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter hier und schaue mir halt so gerne die Krypto ein, an die so wirklich in der Welt eingesetzt wird und auch so die Schwachstellen, die sich nicht nur aus diesen theoretischen Algorithmen ergeben, sondern auch dadurch ergeben, dass man das Zeug wirklich irgendwo auf dem Rechner benutzt. Und deswegen fand man halt DECT, fand ich zumindest DECT sehr interessant, weil es ist halt irgendwas, das benutze ich seit zehn Jahren. Meine Eltern haben irgendwann mein ISDN gekriegt, da kam eine Telefonanlage dazu mit einer Menge Schnurrlostelefone und die hatten damals alles ganz tolle Features, sowas wie ein Telefonbuch oder so im Telefon drin und das war einfach nur grandios, aber ich wusste halt nicht, wie es funktioniert. Ich habe das halt zehn Jahre lang benutzt und hatte halt irgendwie effektiv keine Ahnung über die Sicherheit und das war eine tolle Möglichkeit, sich mal das System anzuschauen.
Ja, da kann ich auch noch was zu sagen. Also ich habe auch zuerst gedacht, es wäre verschlüsselt lange Zeit. Habe es lange Zeit benutzt, denke mir, es ist verschlüsselt, es ist sicher. Und irgendwann überlege ich mal, stimmt das überhaupt?
Und? Stimmt es? Ah, okay, da kommen wir gleich zu. Vielleicht noch mal den Ralf fragen, was so dein Weg zu DECT?
Ja, ich bin früher Mitarbeiter an der Technik-Universität Darmstadt gewesen. Ich habe im April 2008 hier promoviert und bin danach nach Luxemburg gegangen. Habe aber zuvor mit Erik angefangen, an DECT zu forschen. Angefangen hat das, glaube ich, nach dem letzten Kongress. Da dachte ich mir dann so, verdammt, Myfair ist jetzt weg. Was gibt es denn noch so einen proprietärer Krypto, den man irgendwie kaputt machen könnte?
Also Myfair, der RFID-Jet, der von Starbucks und Carsten und so weiter weggeext wurde.
Ja, DECT war dann eben eine der logischen nächsten Ziele. Hat sich dann aber doch ein bisschen hartnäckiger rausgestellt, an die Infos ranzukommen, als es ursprünglich vermutet, weil eben zum Beispiel der DECT-Standard-Zeifer nur wirklich ein Hardware implementiert war. Aber ich meine, im Endeffekt hat es alles geklappt, war nur eben ein etwas längerer Weg, als ursprünglich erwartet.
Das heißt, du bist auch eigentlich mehr so auf der Krypto?
Genau, wie gesagt, ich bin jetzt Postdoc an der Universität Luxemburg bei Alex Pirojukow, einer Gruppe, und mein Hauptgebiet ist eben Kryptoanalyse von allem, was sich bewegt.
Sollen wir vielleicht noch kurz den Werdegang von Masu, soweit er euch bekannt ist, vielleicht noch mit einwerfen? Er hat sich auch schon recht früh mit dem Thema beschäftigt, wenn ich das richtig höre, und hatte da sozusagen schon...
Also ich weiß soweit, dass er sich eine Zeit lang beruflich mit DECT beschäftigt hat, dann halt auf die Karte irgendwie gestoßen ist, gemerkt hat, es gibt keinen Linux-Triver, wollte es aber unter Linux als ganz normale Karte benutzen und hat keine Infos bekommen, hat dann in seinem Blog halt darüber geblockt und Leute gesucht, von denen er Infos bekommt.
Und er hat ja auch gefunden, dann mit dir und den anderen. So, das heißt, auf dem e-Sign habe ich euch da so ein bisschen zusammengetan und dann mit Joint Forces seid ihr irgendwie der Sache sozusagen auf die Spur gekommen. Was ich jetzt erstmal so ganz gerne erarbeiten würde, ich meine, klar, jeder weiß so DECT, alles klar, das ist so, dass da hat man so ein Gerät und dann hat man so die Handsets und damit läuft man dann rum und der eine oder andere wird dann sicherlich auch noch so Details kennen, dass man sich halt mit seinem Gerät auch irgendwie anmelden muss, was ja irgendwie klar ist, weil sonst würde ja jeder mit jedem telefonieren können. Aber was ich jetzt ganz gerne erstmal ein bisschen herausarbeiten würde, ist, wie funktioniert das jetzt eigentlich wirklich? Also, woraus besteht ein DECT-System und wie funktionieren die? Kann da mal jemand ausholen?
Ja, also wir haben eine Basisstation und ein Handset. Die Basisstation ist ständig am Senden, die broadcastet ständig Informationen, wo sie ist, also wer sie ist und wo sie zuhört. Das Handset postet normalerweise gar nichts, bis man abheben will oder telefonieren will. Dann versucht es, eine Verbindung zur Basis aufzubauen. Normalerweise, wenn es wirklich die eigene Basis ist, das sollte sie sein, dann wird die Verbindung aufgebaut und man kann telefonieren.
Gut, aber das ist ja eigentlich der zweite und dritte Schritt. Wenn ich jetzt so ein Ding im Laden kaufe, ich kaufe mir eine Telefonanlage, schließe sie zuhause an den Strom an, dann bootet das Teil. Man konfiguriert ja eigentlich an so einer Basisstation erst mal nichts. Es ist ja nicht wie beim WLAN, dass das Ding einen Namen hätte.
Nö, heutzutage.
Aber trotzdem muss es da ja irgendeine Kennung geben. Also irgendwie muss ja für so ein Handset, müssen sich die Basisstationen irgendwie auseinanderhalten lassen können, oder?
Also die Basisstation hat eine eigene Kennung, die RFPI. Das ist so was Ähnliches wie die SSID, nur die ist vom Hersteller festgelegt. Also sie setzt sich aus Zugriffsrechten, aus Herstellercodes, aus einer Art Seriennummer zusammen.
Das heißt, so ein bisschen wie die MAC-Adresse von so einer Internetkarte.
Genau, und die sollte, wie die MAC-Adresse angeblich auch, zumindest für ein Kontinent oder sogar weltweit eindeutig sein.
Aber? Ist sie nicht?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wieso wahrscheinlich?
Wir haben es noch nicht ausprobiert, also wir hatten noch keine zwei Geräte mit gleicher RFPI, aber rein theoretisch können wir selbst welche so konfigurieren.
Ah, Radio-Fixed-Part-Identity, sagt die allwissende Müllhalde, heißt das.
Genau.
Okay, gut, und das heißt diese Basisstationen kennt aber dann sozusagen, nehme ich mal an, erstmal niemanden.
Also wenn man sie im Laden kauft, sind die normalerweise schon gepaert, das heißt die kennen sich gegenseitig, das Telefon kennt die RFPI. Das Handset, also das Telefon hat auch noch eine eigene ID, die IPEI, das ist eine Art Seriennummer, die sollte auch weltweit eindeutig sein.
IPEI, was hat das auch gesagt, IPEI oder was?
IPEI, International Portable Equipment Identifier.
Ah, IPEI, okay.
Und dann gibt es noch die IPUI, die eben für einen User ist.
Diese wird beim Pern festgelegt. Mit der wird das Handset normalerweise auch angesprochen.
Okay, also die Basisstation hat eine eindeutige Kennung, das Handset hat eine eindeutige Kennung. Und wenn die jetzt sozusagen, also gehen wir mal davon aus, dass die sich jetzt noch nicht kennen, auch wenn das jetzt vielleicht beim Kauf normalerweise anders ist. Also welches Gerät muss jetzt sozusagen die Initiative ergreifen, damit so ein Pairing stattfinden kann, so ein Einbuchen? Ist das dann die Basisstation oder?
Was beim Einbuchen passiert, ist, dass eben die Basisstation eine Challenge schickt an das Handgerät.
Also nicht an das Handgerät, man kennt das ja noch gar nicht.
Rehen wir jetzt über dein Einbuch vor oder reden wir über den, es gibt zwei Vorgänge, es gibt einmal.
Zuerst schalten wir an die Basisstationen Anmeldemodus.
Okay, das ist das, was ich meine. Also man muss sozusagen die Basisstationen in diesen Modus versetzen.
Wichtig, es gibt zwei unterschiedliche, es gibt das heißt Key Allocation, was manche Leute als Anmeldevorgang bezeichnen. Es gibt einen Anmeldevorgang, der passiert, wenn ich mein Telefon einschalte oder meine Basisstation, wenn sie sich bereits kennen.
So ein Login sozusagen. Ich stelle mich das erste Mal vor. Pairing ist, glaube ich, so ein etablierter Begriff. Ich weiß nicht, ob der jetzt bei DECT auch verwendet wird. Dann nehmen wir das Pairing oder technisch. Key Allocation, da merkt man schon, das hat dann eher was mit Verschlüsselung zu tun. Warum heißt das Key Allocation?
Weil es gibt ein gemeinsames Geheimnis zwischen der Basisstation und dem Handset. Das ist 128 Bit lang. Das wird bei diesem Key Allocation-Prozess festgelegt.
Das heißt, jedes Telefon hat dann sein eigenes?
Korrekt. Wenn ich jetzt Telefone habe, dann gibt es in der Basisstation Endslots, die unterschiedliche sogenannte UAKs haben. Diese UAKs sind diese... Muss ich auch nachschauen.
User Authentication Key, glaube ich.
Also noch mal zurückspulen. Die Basisstation wird jetzt in einen Modus versetzt, in dem sie bereit ist, neue Handsets entgegenzunehmen. Dann wird sie in einen Empfängniszustand gebracht.
Korrekt.
So einen Fruchtbarkeitszustand. Und wartet sozusagen auf Befruchtung.
Dann wird das Handset auch in den Anmeldemodus geschaltet. Das sucht dann eine Basis, die im Anmeldemodus ist. Das wird irgendwie über den Funk-Schnitt abgefragt. Und versucht sich dort einzubuchen.
Jetzt muss man erstmal, glaube ich, noch mal darlegen, gefunkt wird, wo, in welchem Bereich, in welchem Frequenzband.
1800 bis 1900 MHz.
1800 bis 1900.
1880 bis 1900, glaube ich.
Und 1920.
1920 bis 1930 sind die DECT-6-0-Frequenzen. Die sind ein bisschen verschoben in den USA. Davon gibt es auch weniger Carriers, nämlich nur fünf.
Okay, also 1,8 bis 1,9 Gigahertz. Und das ist dann wahrscheinlich wieder in Kanäle unterteilt. Wie viele gibt es derer?
In Europa zehn. Und in den USA, also DECT-6-0 hat fünf.
Und die sind dann nochmal getimelistet.
Und sind die komplett anders oder überschneiden die sich?
Die überschneiden sich nicht. Die liegen fast hintereinander.
Das heißt, die amerikanische Version hat weniger Kapazität?
Und weniger Senderleistung.
Und diese Kanäle sind alle gleichberechtigt?
Die sind gleichberechtigt.
Da gibt es jetzt nicht so einen Vermittlungskanal, wo die sich alle unterhalten und so. Das Headset muss jetzt quasi, um so eine Basisstation zu finden, dann permanent alle zehn Kanäle absuchen und schauen, ob da irgendwo auf einem von denen kommuniziert wird.
Das sucht sich den Kanal, wo die Basisstation vorkommt?
Die ist auch nur auf einem?
Die ist vorerst nur auf einem Kanal.
Okay, aber auf irgendeinem?
Auf irgendeinem.
Okay, und die sucht sie sich auf Basis der Europakalzyklusse aus? Okay, gut. Also nimmt sie sich irgendeinen Kanal und sagt, hallo, ich bin eine Basisstation, why don't you join me? Und dann kommt das Handset, scannt das irgendwie alles ab und sagt, oh, da ist ja eine Basisstation. Das ist dann wahrscheinlich die, wo ich jetzt rein soll. Davon ausgehend, dass es jetzt normalerweise nicht gleichzeitig zwei gibt, die rufen.
Wir sind noch bei der Key-Auto-Casheon, ja?
Ich versuche immer noch, diesen Assoziations-Pairing-Vorgang zu verstehen. Also theoretisch, wenn in dem Moment noch eine andere auch die Augen aufhält, dann würde dem Handset jetzt nichts sagen, dass das jetzt die Richtige ist, die gerade gemeint ist.
Nur eine Sache, man gibt normalerweise auch noch eine Pin ein. Wenn die nicht passt, dann wird man nicht angewählt.
Die gibt man in das Handset ein und die wird dann auch mit übertragen.
Genau. Und die gleiche Pin muss natürlich auf der Basisstation. Die wird nicht übertragen, aber kommen wir gleich dazu.
Also wie bei Bluetooth sozusagen. Also ein richtiges Pairing auf beiden Seiten, derselbe Value, der dann wahrscheinlich per Verschlüsselung...
Ja, also das ist ein bisschen anders, als bei Bluetooth. Was passiert ist, dass eben die Basisstation jetzt eine Challenge rausschickt wieder, die besteht aus zwei...
Also nachdem sich das Handset gemeldet hat. Das Handset sieht die Basisstation und sagt, hallo, ich bin's, ich bin ein Telefon, und ich würde gerne bei dir andocken.
Genau, dann sendet es eben Key Allocation Request, kriegt von der Basis eine Challenge, schickt auch selbst wieder eine Challenge zurück.
Also Challenge heißt jetzt für den kryptographischen Prozess?
Genau, für den kryptographischen Prozess. Und antwortet dann auf, also das Handset hat die Challenge erhalten von der Basisstation, schickt auch seinerseits eine Challenge zurück an die Basisstation. Und gleichzeitig schickt es ein Reply, der sich aus dem Shared Secret errechnet, um zu zeigen, dass es eben dieses Shared Secret kennt. Danach authentifiziert die Basisstation nochmal das Handset und das war's dann. Man sieht ja ein kleines Problem an der ganzen Geschichte, nämlich dass die Basisstation nur das Handset authentifiziert und nicht andersrum. Es wird zwar einen zufälliger Wert von Seiten des Telefons geschickt, aber damit wird nicht viel gemacht.
Das heißt, diese Challenge, die das Handset ausschickt, ist eigentlich für die Katz?
Mehr oder weniger, ja.
Mehr oder weniger heißt? Also mehr mehr als weniger. Mehr für die Katz.
Das Problem ist jetzt, dass die Zufallszahlen bei diesem ganzen Prozess, die dann in das Master-Secret eingehen, auch nur von Seiten der Basisstation kommen. Und das heißt, wenn der Zufallszahlengenerator der Basisstation schwach ist und man die PIN kennt oder raten kann, dann kann man das Master-Secret später berechnen. Da werde ich noch mal drauf eingehen später.
Ich wollte jetzt erstmal Verständnis dafür haben, wer redet jetzt eigentlich so mit wem. Da gibt es diese Kryptoschwäche, da werden wir jetzt auf jeden Fall noch drauf kommen. Also es ist so, Basisstation sagt, hallo, ich bin jetzt bereit, neue Händel aufzunehmen. Das Händel sieht es. Wir gehen jetzt von dem guten, normalen Fall aus. Sagt, okay, hallo, hier ich bin es. Dann sprechen wir ein bisschen miteinander. Und danach merkt sich die Basisstation, wahrscheinlich diese Equipment-ID von dem Handset. Das heißt, es kennt dieses Telefon. Und vice versa merkt sich das Handset auch die RFPI von der Basisstation. Und dann sind die erstmal alle glücklich. Und diese IPUI, die du ja vorhin erwähnt hast, kommt die jetzt hier schon zum Tragen? Also ist das dann sozusagen die dynamische Nummer, die diesem Handset zugeteilt wird?
Die wird in dem Moment generiert aus IPEI und ich glaube aus RFPI und wird dann dem Handset zugeordnet.
Ah, okay. Und das weiß das Handset dann auch selber? Oder ist das sozusagen jetzt nur intern, also fliegt das auch übers Netz? Oder ist das nur jetzt so ein theoretischer, so ein abstrakter, wie merke ich mir mein Telefonnummer?
Sie fliegt meines Wissens nach nicht übers Netz.
Meines Wissens jetzt auch nicht. Also wir haben es noch nicht gesnifft, aber genau festlegen kann ich dann jetzt nicht.
Okay, gut. Lass uns das erst mal raus. Also jetzt ist das Handset sozusagen dabei.
Sie müsste bei einem spezifischen Fall über das Netz, nämlich wenn du ein Pagingrequest raussendest.
Ja, ich meine jetzt, die fliegt nicht übers Netz beim Pairing.
Nein, nein.
Ich meine das überhaupt irgendwann mal.
Dann klar wird das Telefon über die Luft mit der ID angesprochen.
Genau. Es gibt aber noch eine zweite, die...
Das ist die Temporary Portable Unit Identifier.
Das ist so was wie bei GSM, wo man eben sagt, man will nicht, dass die Geräte nun mal dauernd übertragen wird, weil es die Leute dann ja identifiziert fühlen könnten. Und dann vergibt man eben etwas, was nur temporär ist und was auch irgendwie eindeutig sein soll, aber nicht trackbar. Also sie haben sogar ein bisschen an Anonymity gedacht an der Stelle, aber...
Funktioniert nicht so richtig. Okay, das nehmen wir gleich nochmal auseinander. Das heißt, so baut man sich jetzt so sein Setup auf und die Handsets kennen die Basisstation. Paging, was du gerade angesprochen hast, das ist so diese ich such mein Telefon Funktionalität, oder?
Richtig, genau. Nein, ich ruf mein Telefon an.
Also wenn jetzt die Basisstation einen Anruf reinbekommt, dann sendet die, also dann broadcastet die mit ihren normalen Paketen noch ein paar andere Pakete mit, die sagen, hier kommt ein Anruf, an dieses, dieses und dieses Handset klingelt jetzt. Dann fangen die an zu klingeln und wenn jemand abhebt, bauen die die Verbindung auf. Also immer das Handset baut die Verbindung auf.
Das sagt einfach, ich nehme den Call jetzt an. Und dann irgendwie für das Kampf, für das Surf.
Und baut dann auch die Sendeverbindung zur Basis auf.
Da könnten wir vielleicht nochmal auf einen wichtigen Punkt mit den Kanälen eingehen, was die PP-Geschichte angeht.
Genau. Also das FP, die Station, die broadcastet dich nur...
Also FP, fixed part, das ist sozusagen der technische Begriff für die Basis. FP, PP, kommt bestimmt noch häufiger.
Die broadcastet nicht nur rum, ich bin da, sondern die broadcastet auch rum. Ich höre dann und dann auf diesem Kanal, auf diesem Slot, dann auf diesem Kanal, diesem Slot, diesem Slot, diesem Slot.
Vorher schon? Die gibt immer vorher bekannt, auf welchem Kanal sie gleich lauscht?
Genau.
Ah, so eine Art Sprechzeiten.
Sprechstunde ist irgendwie.
Und auf einem dieser Kanäle und Slots meldet sich das PP. Das sucht sich den aus, wo am wenigsten Verkehr ist, wo kein großes Rauschen ist und fängt dort an zu senden.
Das ist auch sinnvoll, weil, ich meine, die Perspektive, was jetzt rauschfrei ist, ist ja für das PP nur zu sehen. Ich meine, der mag für die FP irgendwie komplett anders aussehen. Deswegen sucht sich eben das PP heraus, wo es seinen Müll hinbläst.
Wie sehr wird denn ein Kanal, also wenn ich jetzt so ein Telefongespräch führe, wie voll ist denn dann der Kanal? Also wie wenig kann das von einem zweiten Handset mitgenutzt werden gleichzeitig?
Also normalerweise so im Normalbetrieb, wie es jetzt zum Beispiel bei mir zu Hause ist, hat ich höchstens zwei Basisstationen auf einem Kanal.
Du wohnst aber auch auf dem Land, muss man dazu sagen. An meinen beiden Wohnorten habe ich 30.
Oh, 30 Basisstationen auf einem Kanal?
Nein, auf allen Kanälen. Aber seltsamerweise sind die irgendwie geclustert. Also ich habe irgendwie Kanäle, da sind dann plötzlich 8 oder 10 und dann gibt es halt Kanäle, die sind komplett frei. Ich habe keine Erklärung dafür, aber...
Das liegt wahrscheinlich irgendwo in der Software dieser Basisstation.
Also auf dem Kongress war es ganz interessant, da hingen so viele Basisstationen rum, die waren ständig einen Kanal am wechseln, weil sie sich gegenseitig gestört haben.
Ah, der Kongress ist ja voll mit DECT seit vielen Jahren. Da kommen wir sicherlich auch gleich nochmal dazu. Aber was ich jetzt eigentlich gerade meinte ist, wenn ich jetzt mit einem Telefon, also wenn ich wirklich ein Telefongespräch führe, dann wird ja der Kanal, nehme ich mal an, nicht mehr gewechselt.
Doch, das kann passieren. Sobald eine andere Station reinrutscht, also zwei Basisstationen sind nie wirklich synchron, solange sie nicht zum gleichen Netz gehören. Das heißt, es kann mir passieren, dass während der Übertragung durch verschiedene Frequenzen, auf denen die Geräte schwingen, die Pakete von dem einen Geräten, das andere reinrutschen, dann muss ein Gerät einen Kanal oder einen Slot wechseln.
Verstehe, das haben wir noch gar nicht angesprochen. Es gibt natürlich das Problem der Synchronicität, wenn man Kanäle hat. Also ist das so ein Timeslot-Verfahren? Das heißt, beide an der Kommunikation beteiligten Geräte müssen eigentlich eine selbe Vorstellung davon haben, wann so ein Slot anfängt und wann er aufhört.
Genau.
Wer synchronisiert sich da auf wen?
Die Basisstationen geben vor, und die PPs synchronisieren sich darauf.
Aber wenn jetzt zwei Basisstationen rumstehen, also separate Telefonanlagen, die mit anderen nichts zu tun haben, aber dann eben den gleichen Kanal benutzen, dann hacken die unter Umständen gegenseitig rein. Und welches Gerät ist jetzt gezwungen, das festzustellen, dass das stattfindet? Haben diese Basisstationen so serienmäßig so einen Detektor, dass sie andere Basisstationen erkennen und dann auf einen anderen Kanal ausweichen oder weichen die sowieso permanent auf andere Kanäle aus?
Die weichen normalerweise nicht aus, aber hauptsächlich empfangen die sich gegenseitig gar nicht. Die Basisstationen.
Also, können die das überhaupt merken? Du hast ja gerade gesagt, es findet einen Wechsel statt auf einem anderen Kanal. Wodurch wird der ausgelöst?
Normalerweise durch das PP. Das merkt, mir kommt hier jemand anders in die Quere.
Ah, okay. Weil er einfach sieht, dass da jemand anders kommuniziert.
Interessanterweise ändern ja auch die Basisstationen ihre Kanäle ab und zu.
Ja.
Wodurch wird das initiiert?
Obwohl, die lauschen auf den Kanälen von den PPs. Falls dort jemand reinrutscht, könnten die wechseln. Also falls in die eigenen PP-Kanäle jemand reinrutscht, der nicht zur Station gehört. Also wenn das PP einen Kanal aufbaut, dann broadcastet das die RFPI der Basisstation mit. Wenn jetzt eine andere Basisstation auf ihren Kanälen diese abscannt, eine RFPI findet, die nicht passt, dann denke ich mal wechselt es den Kanal.
Ah, okay. Das heißt, ausgelöst durch die Handsets können die Basisstationen sozusagen da folgen. PPFP, wo sind wir denn jetzt? Wir haben dieses Problem mit der Taktung. Jetzt hast du gerade gesagt, die PP-Kanäle, also wählen denn die Handsets auch selber einfach aus, auf welchem Kanal sie mit dieser Basisstation reden wollen?
Ja, die Basisstationen gehen durch, die gehen die einzelnen Kanäle durch, frameweise. Das heißt, 24 Slots auf einem Kanal, dann kommt der nächste Kanal dran und wieder ein nächstes Kanal. Und so ein PP wartet eigentlich, bis der Kanal kommt, auf dem es senden will, wartet dann einen Slot ab, wo die Basis zuhört und sendet dann, baut hier ihre Verbindung auf. Da gibt es vielleicht noch was zu sagen. Und zwar, wir haben 24 Slots und die Sende- und Empfangsslots liegen immer 12 auseinander. Das heißt, wenn Basis auf Slot 0 sendet, sendet PP, also Portable, auf Slot 12.
Ah, zurück sozusagen, die Hin- und Herkommunikation zwischen zwei. Und das tun sie deshalb, damit die sozusagen zeitlich maximal weit auseinander sind?
Das und dass man das überhaupt nicht koordinieren muss. Also es ist ganz klar, dass dann 12 Slots später eine Antwort kommt.
Ah, verstehe. Okay, das heißt, man spart sich da nochmal so ein extra Handshake.
Genau.
So, was haben wir jetzt vergessen? Wir hatten diese eigentliche Einbuchung an der Basisstation und der andere Einbuchungsvorgang, den du meintest, ist ja sozusagen, ich will ein Telefongespräch aufnehmen.
Entweder ich will jetzt ein Telefongespräch beginnen oder auch ich schalte mein Telefon zum ersten Mal ein, nachdem ich die Basisstation gebootet habe. Und da passiert dann eben auch nochmal ein Anmeldevorgang. Der sieht dann so aus, dass, also da gibt es mehrere Optionen dafür, aber normalerweise sieht er so aus, dass die Basisstation wieder eine Challenge schickt und das PP dann eben mithilfe des UAKs aus der Challenge eine Response berechnet und zurückschickt. Das ist ein zweistufiges Verfahren. Da wird erstmal ein KS berechnet, ein Session Key sozusagen. Und aus diesem KS wird dann die Response und der optionalen Cipher Key berechnet. Prinzipiell wäre es auch möglich, dass die Basisstation noch mal sagen könnte, hey, Basisstation, ich will aber auch wissen, dass du wirklich der bist, als der du dich ausgibst. Dieser Authentifizierungsschritt wird aber in den meisten Fällen weggelassen, haben wir gesehen. Und das führt natürlich dazu, dass an der Stelle auch Angriffe möglich sind.
Okay, ich wollte, dass wir jetzt gleich noch mal den Kripto-Teil ein bisschen aufbewahren und erst mal so verstehen, wie es eigentlich funktioniert. Haben wir jetzt an der grundsätzlichen Funktionalität, war es das jetzt schon irgendwie? Ist das alles, was DECT irgendwie kann? Also man meldet sich das erste Mal an, man meldet sich an, wenn man wieder eingeschaltet wird, man nimmt einen Ruf an oder man initiiert diesen Ruf?
Es gibt noch einen extra Kanal, also nicht jetzt frequenzmäßig, sondern in den Daten, der ist zum Signaling, das heißt zum Wählen von Rufnummern, zum Öffnen von Türen, überhaupt so Tastenübertragung oder Special Features, wie zum Beispiel eingegangene Rufe, ähnliches, also eingegangene Rufe bei Abwesenheit. Das wird alles über den Kanal gemacht.
Du redest über den C-Kanal?
Genau.
Darüber wird auch die Authentifizierung gefahren?
Stimmt, ja.
Also es gibt doch einen speziellen Kanal.
Das ist aber kein physikalischer Kanal, das ist ein logischer Kanal.
Ach so, verstehe.
Das nennen wir die physikalischen Kanäle eigentlich Carrier, so werden sie auch in den Specs genannt.
Und die logischen sind dann die wirklichen Kanäle?
Genau.
Ah, okay, gut. Und da wird dann unterschieden zwischen Kanäle, auf denen ich telefoniere, und Kanäle, auf denen diese Metadaten sozusagen ausgetragen werden. Also vergleichweise zu dem D-Kanal bei ISDN, wo ja auch eingehende Anrufe und so weiter.
Bei denen können auch so Scherzen gemacht werden, wie Menüs angezeigt beim Handshake und sowas.
Und hier ist das C-Kanal. Und was ist jetzt sozusagen vom DECT-Standard da alles definiert? Also sowas wie, ich blätter in meinem Telefonbuch.
Das ist proprietäre Erweiterung.
Das heißt, das funktioniert auch immer nur Siemens Telefon mit Siemens Telefonanlage und so weiter.
Ja, natürlich schon. AVM hat das jetzt zum Beispiel auch mit ihren Produkten mit drin, dass die mit ihren AVM-Anlagen ihre Menüs auf Siemens Telefone schicken können.
Aber ich denke, da wurde freundlich nachgefragt, oder?
Ja, so in der Art. Vielleicht hat man noch ein bisschen Menschen gefragt oder eine Software von Siemens.
Hauptsache, man kriegt eine Auskunft.
Vielleicht von C-Kanal fällt mir gerade noch ein, kann man noch sagen, so ein Paket besteht grundsätzlich aus A-Feld und B-Feld. Der normale Podcast ist nur A-Feld, d.h. ganz kleine Datenmenge, ein paar Bytes, wo gerade das Nötigste drinsteht. Wenn man dann eine Übertragung öffnet und wirklich Daten überträgt, wird das B-Feld dazugeschaltet. Das kann normalerweise verschiedene Längen haben, hat bei Konsumergeräten aber eine Standardlänge. Da gehen die reinen Sprachdaten zum Beispiel drüber. Mit einem gewissen Codec, nur mit einer kleinen Checksumme geschützt und möglicherweise noch verschlüsselt und für das Senden aufbereitet.
Gibt es denn, also ISDN ist ja so, naja, das ist zwar jetzt alles digital, aber es ist gemacht fürs Telefonieren. Und man kann dann aber eben auch explizit Daten-Calls machen. Gibt es sowas auch für DECT? Das ist also ein Standard auch schon vorgesehen?
Ja, das sind 64-Kbit-Kanäle normalerweise. Es gibt aber meines Wissens nach bei der neueren Generation von DECT, das ist sogenannte DECT Next Generation, was glaube ich erst Ende des letzten Jahres standardisiert wurde, gibt es auch die Möglichkeit, wesentlich breitbandiger zu übertragen. Die verwenden dann auch eine andere Modulation.
Benutzt das irgendjemand?
Noch nicht meines Wissens. Aber die Hersteller...
Ich meine, benutzt diesen Daten-Übertrag überhaupt irgendjemand?
Ja, wir haben zum Beispiel auch von DOSCH und Amand so Free Pads, also kleine Computer mit Tabs. DOSCH und Amand, wo auch die Common Air-Karte herkommt. So kleine Free Pads, also tragbare Computer mit Tabs und internem DECT-Chip-Satz. Und die machen darüber ISDN.
Also es ist auch kein WLAN-Datenübertrag, weil das wahrscheinlich ziemlich fesch ist.
Genau.
So war es wahrscheinlich auch irgendwann mal gedacht, dass DECT einfach das Komplement ist, dass sozusagen das WLAN für ISDN.
Dann gibt es noch so EC-Karten-Terminals zum Bezahlen in Restaurants, die über DECT angebunden sind, Datenverbindungen. Und es gibt noch so Verkehrsleitsysteme, die auch Daten über DECT übertragen, sind in Großbritannien, angeblich, ziemlich weit verbreitet.
Jetzt wird es ein bisschen unanständig, glaube ich.
Ja, wer sich noch für DECT-Technik interessiert, wer gerne Bahn fährt, besonders im ICE, da ist auch noch ein bisschen was drin verbaut.
Ja, also die Durchsagen dort gehen sehr wahrscheinlich auch über DECT.
Aha, aber es ist ja alles ganz sicher und verschlüsselt.
Ja, ja.
Da kann ja nichts passieren. Bevor wir da jetzt in diese Diskussion einsteigen, habe ich hier noch ein Gesprächsthemenkarte. Der DECT-Standard sieht ja auch das Roaming vor, oder? Also wenn ich jetzt eine große Firma bin, und ich habe da große Lagerhallen, die Leute laufen da mit DECT-Telefonen rum, dann muss das ja sozusagen über die normale Reichweite, die, glaube ich, bei 50 Metern liegt, so indoor, für eine Basisstation. Also von der Spezifikation her, wie langsam wirklich hält es noch mal eine andere Frage. Muss es ja so ein Handover geben können, so wie man das von GSM auch kennt, wenn man mit seinem Handy im Zug durch die Gegend fährt und so weiter. Man muss ja jetzt nicht jedes Mal wieder neu einbuchen. ZB das macht das Telefon dann automatisch. Das gibt es bei DECT auch.
Das gibt es bei DECT auch.
Ist das dieses GAP?
Nein, das ist etwas ganz anderes. Da müssen wir auch nur dazu kommen.
Okay, also wie ist das mit dem Roaming?
Also das läuft erstmal über die RFPI. Die muss da ein bisschen anders aussehen. Bei größeren Anlagen hat die z.B. vorne eine 1.0. Daran ist das schön zu erkennen. Und die sind dann meistens durchnummeriert oder sogar gleich. Und das Telefon sucht sich dann die stärkste Station aus.
Aber wenn die RFPI von den einzelnen Stationen gleich ist, wie kann dann das Telefon dann noch zwischen denen unterscheiden?
Das muss nicht unterscheiden.
Ach so, alles klar, verstehe. Das heißt, das Telefon merkt gar nichts davon, dass es gerohmt wird. Aber es kann auch was davon merken. Es kann auch selber rum, sozusagen.
Normalerweise initiiert solche Sachen immer das PP. Die Stationen sind relativ statisch und dumm in dem Fall.
Das heißt, das Telefon selber merkt, wo es das stärkste Signal bekommt oder das fehlerfreiste Signal. Und sucht sich dann sozusagen seine Basisstation selber aus.
Genau, sagt der Basisstation, wo es angemeldet ist, bescheid und wechselt dann.
Aber es gibt keinen Standard für, wie verschiedene Basisstationen sich untereinander unterhalten, um das zu koordinieren?
Nein, es gibt nur was anderes. Und zwar ist in DECT sowas wie Fremdnetzer vorgesehen. Das heißt, ich könnte so Spielereien machen wie, dass ich zum Beispiel bei mir daheim eine DECT-Anlage habe und du hast ebenfalls auch eine bei dir daheim. Und dann kann ich die Anlagen miteinander koppeln, dass ich sage, okay, die beiden Anlagen sollen sich jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen miteinander vertrauen. Und wenn ich dann zu dir nach Hause komme, kann ich mein Telefon nehmen. Und das bucht sich dann praktisch über deine Anlage in mein Heimatnetz ein. Das ist vorgesehen. Das ist auch mit GSM so. Ich kann jetzt irgendwie mir in Deutschland irgendwo beim beliebigen Anbieter mir eine SIM-Karte holen, fahre damit nach Frankreich und dann kann ich halt irgendein französisches Netz telefonieren.
Das wird auch für dich durchgetunnelt sozusagen, die Authentifisierung.
Genau, das ist so vorgesehen. Dann würde meine Anlage jetzt praktisch eine Art temporären Zwischen-Schlüssel generieren und auch irgendwie eine Antwort auf einen Challenge-Response-Pair und so weiter. Dann wird das alles zu deiner Anlage rüberschieben. Und die Anlage bei dir würde dann wirklich auch nochmal das Ganze dann weiter senden und kann dann auch wiederum mit diesem Zwischen-Schlüssel erkennen, ob meine Antwort auf die Antwort von meinem Telefon korrekt war.
Benutzt das Feature irgendjemand?
Meines Wissens noch nicht.
Nein, aber es ist relativ cool, dass es drin ist. Es ist wirklich so vorgesehen, so mein geheimer UAK, mein geheimer Schlüssel, der bleibt wirklich auf meinem Telefon und auf meiner Anlage daheim. Und ich kann dann so eine Art Zwischen-Schlüssel weitergeben, ein Fremdnetz rein und so.
Das ist der sogenannte KS, von dem wir vorhin schon mal sprachen.
Was hat es jetzt mit diesem GAP auf sich? Das ist ja die Abkürzung, die man auch immer wieder sieht.
Und das spezifiziert so Minimal-Anforderungen, was Handset und eine Basisstation können müssen, um interoperabel miteinander zu sein. Weil man hat ja natürlich viele verschiedene Hersteller. Und am Anfang war es eben so, dass eine Hersteller A dann die Basisstation hatte, die nicht mit dem Handset von Hersteller D zusammengearbeitet hat. Und daraufhin wurde eben das Generic Access Profile standardisiert. Und dieses standardisiert dann auch den, oder im Zuge dessen wurde eben auch dieser DECT-Standard Authentication Algorithm standardisiert und der DECT-Standard-Zeifer. Und da stehen dann so unterschiedliche Profile drin, wie man authentifiziert. Und ja, das ist so die Grundlage, auf dem Interoperabilität geschaffen wurde.
Und sind denn alle Telefone heutzutage nach GAP?
Alle eigentlich, ja.
Die man jetzt kaufen kann im Laden.
Es sei denn, man kauft explizit auf IPEI irgendwas, das 12 Jahre alt ist.
Aber wie groß ist das Problem von Inkompatibilitäten so bei DECT?
Es geht so. Ich hatte jetzt mal ein relativ billiges Telefon. Normalerweise läuft das halt so, man drückt auf der Basis ein Knopf zum Telefon anmelden und dann kann man auf dem Telefon im Menü sagen, jetzt anmelden. Dann meldet sich das Telefon an. Und das funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut. Allerdings habe ich jetzt mal eine Basisstation erwischt, da gibt es diese Knöpfchen nicht, sondern man steckt einfach das Telefon in die Ladeschale rein. Und dann meldet sich das an. Und wenn das Telefon nicht die passenden Ladekontakte hat, dann geht es halt nicht. Aber ansonsten ist die Interoperabilität zwischen den Herstellern eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Und die sind gapfähig?
Ich weiß nicht, ob gap drauf steht, aber jedenfalls war es ein neues DECT-Telefon, was irgendwo in einem großen Elektronikmarkt im Regal lag.
Ja, auf dem Chaos-Communication-Kongress in Berlin jüngst, wo ihr auch den Vortrag gehalten habt, gibt es ja seit, also auf dem Kongress gibt es und auf CZD-Vereinscheidungen seit Längerem, gibt es schon seit Längerem DECT-Infrastruktur. Das wird dort wild benutzt. Von daher ist das ja sozusagen auch eine Technologie, die ohnehin mal unter die Lupe genommen werden musste. Ich habe mit dem Sascha, der das macht, vom POG, auch schon mal hier bei CAE, irgendwann mal darüber geredet. Aber ihr habt euch ja sicherlich diese Anlage jetzt in dem Zusammenhang dann auch technisch noch mal genauer angeschaut. Vielleicht, was gibt es dazu zu sagen?
Die Jungs waren echt schlau, weil sie haben uns die Möglichkeit genommen, ein Live-Hack zu demonstrieren, indem sie einfach die Verschlüsselung und die Authentifizierung komplett abgeschaltet haben.
Auf der Easter-Hack war die auch nicht angeschaltet. Da haben wir dann sehr viel rumprobiert, auf der Easter-Hack zum Anschalten. Da gingen auf einmal alle Telefone nicht mehr, weil sie neu angemeldet hätten müssen, weil halt nicht die richtigen Sachen ausgetauscht wurden.
Eigentlich hätte ich gerne so eine Demo gemacht, wie extrahiere ich meinen URK. Aber das ging eben nicht, weil es keinen URK gibt.
Gab es jetzt einen besonderen Grund, die Krypto auszuschalten?
Doch, die hatten damit weniger Kompatibilitätsprobleme und es liefen halt mehr Telefone dadurch.
Alles klar.
Also wenn du halt ein Telefon hast, wo die Krypto extrahant sich implementiert ist, dann funktioniert das halt einfach nicht. Und wo wir leben, ist auch, man kann das wohl in der Anlage nicht selektiv abschalten für manche Telefone. Dass man halt einfach sagt, okay, 95 Prozent machen halt Krypto. Und die fünf Prozent, wo ich halt irgendwie weiß, das Telefon ist ranzig, dann sage ich halt pro Telefon einfach hier, Krypto aus. Das geht halt nicht, sondern da gibt es halt nur ein globales Level. Und wenn man das halt einfach auf, benutzt gar keine Krypto und fragt gar nicht nach Authentifizierung, sondern macht einfach, stellt, dann funktioniert halt eigentlich alles.
Ja, da fehlt noch mal so die passende Open-Source-Telefonanlage, die DECT macht. Oder gibt es da was?
Ja, wir würden uns freuen, wenn jemand mal einen DECT-Stack implementiert.
Ja, kann man denn das so einfach? Ich meine, die DECT-Spezifikationen, wie geheim ist das so alles?
Das ist eigentlich völlig offen bis auf den DSC und den DSAA.
Und das sind die?
Die Kryptoroutinen, die braucht man nicht unbedingt. Die braucht man, wenn man gapfähig sein will, aber anders braucht man die nicht.
DSAA ist der DECT-Standard-Organisation-Algorithm und DSC ist der DECT-Standard-Zeifer.
Das heißt, wenn man die Krypto weglässt, spricht eigentlich gar nichts dagegen. Da müsste man sich sozusagen nur die entsprechende Funk-Hardware irgendwie bauen oder organisieren.
Die gibt es schon als Common-Air-Karte oder sowas.
Common-Air-Karte, jetzt haben wir es schon 1000 Mal erwähnt, jetzt müssen wir mal sagen, was das ist. Das ist so eine PC, PCMCIA oder PC-Card. People can't memorize computer industry acronyms. Ja, deswegen nennt man das auch PC-Card. Gut, also wir wissen alle, wovon die Rede ist. Viele Notebooks haben da so einen Slot zum Reinstecken. Und was macht diese Karte?
Das ist eigentlich nur ein DECT-Baseband, also ein Chip, der das ganze Timing und die Hardware-Schieberei für die DECT-Funk-Schnittstelle macht und ein AF-Modul, das das dann auch noch sendet und empfängt.
Das heißt, da ist keine wirkliche, vollständige Telefonlogik drin, sondern eigentlich nur der Teil, der funkt. Und dann kann man das eben entsprechend nutzen, aber dazu braucht man einen Treiber.
Genau.
Und den gibt es dazu?
Den sind wir am Schreiben.
Den gab es aber sonst nicht mit dem Produkt dazu?
Es gab einen Windows-Treiber, dort hat das Gerät eine Basisstation emuliert, worüber man telefonieren konnte. Die hat nicht verschlüsselt, aber man konnte halt über Sieb telefonieren.
Das heißt, das ist im Prinzip genauso eine Implementierung mit, man lässt jetzt erstmal Krypto raus, aber man kann sozusagen teilnehmen.
Genau.
Und ihr schreibt einen neuen Treiber dafür, oder habt schon einen neuen Treiber geschrieben?
Sind dran.
Seid dabei, ihn zu schreiben. Der funktioniert schon ein bisschen.
Wir haben im Moment einen Sniffer.
Für Linux nehme ich jetzt an.
Wir haben einen Sniffer. Und falls wir Hilfe kriegen, bauen wir auch noch Basisstationen und Telefonen, wobei das sehr viel Aufwand ist. Laut mal so wären das vier Mann Jahre, aber vielleicht kriegen wir noch genug Hilfe, für einen DECT-Standard zu bauen.
Ohne noch Männer.
Ja, also wir treten halt dafür einen vollständigen Protocol-Stack.
Es können auch gerne Frauenjahre von mir aus sein.
Das wollte ich auch gar nicht ausschließen, aber der Begriff steht ja nun mal als solcher.
Dann weißt du zumindest, dass das nicht meine Zeit ist.
Ja, also die...
Oder vier Fraujahre.
Das sollten wir jetzt nicht weiter vertiefen. Auf jeden Fall, da gibt es Bedarf. Diese Common Air-Karte, gibt es denn noch irgendwas anderes, oder ist das jetzt irgendwie das Einzige, was überhaupt auf dem Markt verfügbar ist? Das ist gar nicht mehr verfügbar, oder? Die Firma gibt es nicht mehr? Die wird nicht mehr hergestellt.
Es gibt noch einen Restposten, aber das war es auch. Sonst haben wir noch das USRP. Also Sniffen ist uns bis jetzt gelungen.
USRP, das wollen wir ein bisschen aufholen. Das ist diese Spezial-Hardware, die eigentlich im Rahmen des GSM-Projektes mal entwickelt wurde? Genau, Gnu Radio entwickelt wurde, die unter anderem auch im GSM-Projekt verwendet wird, um eben GSM zu simulieren, aber kann man eben auch verwenden, um seine eigene Radarinstallation zu basteln. Das ist so ein Bauset, das kann man sich für ein paar Hundert Euro klicken. Ich weiß nicht, wo lag der Preis, 800 oder so was? Gibt es dafür schon Software, die DECT macht?
Nur einen Sniffer. Wir haben das mit dem Timing nicht gut hingekriegt. Aber es gibt ja eine GSM-Basisstation auf Basis vom USRP. Deshalb sollte das auch mit DECT gehen.
Mit dem USRP-V2 sollte das Timing wesentlich besser klappen, hat Erik Blossom gesagt.
Ja klar, es hat ja viel größere Bandbreite für Timing.
Das ist aber auch schon ein halbes Jahr her. Ich weiß nicht, wie es heißt, wenn USRP-V2 kommt.
Inzwischen ist es da.
Das Problem bei DECT ist ganz einfach, dass so eine Frequenz in 24 Zeitslust unterteilt ist. Wenn man einen Sniffer bauen will, um das Paket korrekt zu lesen, muss man sehr genau wissen, wann das Paket bei einem eingetroffen ist. Wenn man ein Gerät hat, das die Pakete über USB reinschiebt, weiß man nicht ganz genau, wann das Paket eingetroffen ist. Dann funktioniert das mit Sniffen nicht so genau.
Nicht nur, wann das Paket eingetroffen ist, sondern auch, wann es verarbeitet wird. Die Pakete werden immer in größeren Päckchen verarbeitet, in den einzelnen Schritten. Deshalb weiß man nicht wirklich genau, wann welches Paket eingetroffen ist.
Man möchte so nah wie möglich ein Medium sein, um alle Bedingungen zu kennen.
Es gibt noch eine zweite Hardware, die wahrscheinlich für so etwas geeignet wäre. Das ist die Fritzbox 7270. Die hat nämlich einen ähnlichen Chip. Das ist ein National Semiconductor, heute heißt es Side Health Semiconductor. Auf der Common Air-Karte ist ein SC-14421. Auf der Fritzbox 7270 ist ein SC-14480, wenn ich mich recht entsinne. Der hat im Unterschied zu dem 21er noch einen eingebauten DSP. Den muss man aber nicht verwenden. Der hat ansonsten vom Dedicated Instruction Prozessor wahrscheinlich die gleichen Befehlsatz.
Oder zumindest einen erweiterten Befehlsatz.
Das heißt, wir könnten die Firmware, die wir für den 21er haben, wahrscheinlich auch darauf laufen lassen.
Also was in der Common-Rkarte drückt.
Genau. Was auch bei dieser Box schön ist, die hat uns nämlich auch beim Debugging von den ganzen UAK-Geschichten sehr geholfen, ist, dass AVM ein sehr schönes Debug-Interface entwickelt hat. Es gibt dort einen Device-Dev-Debug.
Läuft denn die Fritzbox unter Linux?
Richtig, genau. Es gibt etwas, das heißt Frizz, F-R-E-E-T-Z. Das ist etwas Open-WRT-ähnliches für die Fritzbox. Sehr nett, kann man sich seine Konfiguration selbst zusammenklicken und compilen. Auch sehr komfortabel. Wenn man das installiert, kommt man mit einem SSH drauf. Dann hat man Zugriff auf diese Debug-Funktionalität, kann sich das DECT-EPROM ausgeben lassen, wo in der UR-Card steht. Man kann sich das komplette Pairing anschauen. Man hat einen DECT-Monitor drin, der sagt, ob die Verbindung zu dem Handset verschlüsselt ist oder nicht, auf welchem Kanal und auf welchem Timestop das abläuft. Das ist zum Debugging sehr hilfreich. Was noch sehr hilfreich ist, Sie haben ein Kernel-Modul gebaut, das den DECT-Stack implementiert. Das hat volle Symbole. Für die Leute, die hier reverse-ingenieren, ihr wisst, was das heißt.
Man kann da sehr gut nachvollziehen, welches Software da wirklich ausgeführt wird zur Laufzeit.
Genau.
Wie weit ist denn das? Davon hatte ich noch gar nichts gehört, von diesen Freetz.
Das ist funktionsfähig.
Das heißt, das bildet auch die Funktionalität der Telefonanlage vollständig nach.
Genau, das ist eine Erweiterung praktisch. Da AVM GPL-Software verwendet hat, mussten sie den Source dafür auch rausrücken, inklusive Bildenvironment. Ich weiß nicht, ob daran Harald beteiligt war, aber ich habe ihn so verstanden. Und dann haben eben die Freetz-Entwickler ihre eigene Distribution gebastelt. Und die enthält dann auch die Telefonanlagen-Funktionalität? Das heißt, man kann sagen, ich habe zum Beispiel dieses UMTS-Modul an einer Freetz-Box 7270 zu Hause dranhängen.
Dieses UMTS-Modul ist das, was du ja jetzt auf dem Tisch gelegt hast?
Genau, das, was aus dem Tisch liegt.
Jawohl, ist es weiß, eckig, ein großer deutscher Netzverwalter hat sein Logo draufgebaut.
Und unten drauf steht Huawei.
Das ist alles Huawei.
Und was ist mit dem Modul? Das läuft da dran. Und auf der anderen Seite ist es eben noch eine ganz normale DECT-Basisstation für mich.
Interessant.
Allerdings muss man dazu sagen, AVM hat zwar die Körnenquellen rausgegeben, allerdings die Module, die DECTen, die sind komplett closed source.
Klar, aber wie gesagt, volle Symbole.
Aber es gibt jetzt sozusagen noch keinen DECT-Stack für Linux?
Nein, keinen der Open Source ist.
Aber das wäre jetzt eigentlich mal genau das, was man bräuchte?
Genau, das würden wir gerne haben.
Da wird ja auch an interessierten Programmierern interessiert, falls jetzt jemand schon die Ohren gespitzt hat. Ich wollte auch nochmal kurz hinweisen, ich habe mit Harald Welte ja ein längeres Gespräch geführt über Software Defined Radio, Chaos Radio Express 087. Da ging es im Wesentlichen um genug Radio und natürlich auch um diese USRP-Plattform. Also wer da sich mal ein bisschen reindenken möchte, dem sei auch diese Sendung nochmal ans Herz gelegt. Und wenn man halt wirklich Lust hätte, aus den bisher gewonnenen Erkenntnissen, bzw. die haben wir schon gelernt, das Protokoll DECT an sich ist ja auch offen standardisiert. Solange jetzt Krypto nicht beteiligt ist, kann man das einfach alles implementieren. Und wenn man das Ganze dann noch in so einen Kernelstack werfen würde, dann hätte man dann auch gleich mit der AVM Hardware im Prinzip auch eine volle Umgebung. Das heißt, man könnte selber mal DECT-Telefonanlage sein und einen möglichen Unfug machen.
Eigentlich auch mit der Common Air-Karte.
Die es aber nicht mehr gibt.
Ach so, stimmt.
Die Restposten habt ihr euch wahrscheinlich schon alle gesichert, wie ich euch kenne. Nicht alle, nein.
Noch ein paar. Bei der AVM müssten wir kurz noch schauen, wie man die Chip da genau ansteuert. Aber das sollte dann eher das kleinere Problem sein.
Gut, so, jetzt sind wir natürlich an einem interessanten Punkt angekommen. Ich fasse nochmal ein bisschen zusammen. Also DECT, ewig wohl definierter Standard, mit so einem Geheimteil, der Krypto, funktioniert erstmal so straight forward. Und auf den ersten Blick denkt man so, aha, okay, Krypto ist ja irgendwie sicher. Jetzt haben wir schon in den Zwischentönen hier und da gehört. Ganz so sicher ist es nicht, weil es einfach viele mögliche Angriffspunkte gibt. Was habt ihr denn jetzt sozusagen in eurer Analyse herausgefunden über die Sicherheit von DECT und wo es krankt?
Wir haben angefangen mit, unser erster Angriff war, der hat überhaupt keine Krypto erfolgt, der hat uns einfach nur mal verifizieren lassen, dass man die Handsets auch dazu bekommt, Krypto abzuschalten oder nicht anzuschalten, wenn man es ihnen sagt. Das heißt, unser erster Angriff war komplett trivial. Wir haben uns einfach Software genommen, die leicht modifiziert RFPIs geschickt hat von einer anderen Basisstation.
Also so getan hat, als wäre sie selber eine.
Genau.
Mit dieser Common Air-Karte.
Mit irgendwas. Das tut jetzt nicht gerade nichts zur Sache.
Gut, alles klar.
Ich habe nichts gesagt. Dann haben wir festgestellt, ja, unsere Handsets, die mögen auch mit unserer anderen Lösungen reden, wenn wir nur stärker funken als die andere Basisstation.
Und dieselbe RFPI verwendet.
Genau, die gleiche RFPI.
Das tut sozusagen so, als wäre die eigentliche Basisstation.
Ein wichtiger Schritt noch, wenn dieses Challenge-Response- Verfahren kommt, also wir schicken eine Challenge raus, weil wir sind ja die Basisstation an das Handset. Wir wissen natürlich den Schlüssel leider nicht. Also sagen wir für jede Antwort, die uns das Telefon schickt, ja, passt schon, machen wir weiter.
Und die andere Basisstation, die eigentliche, die stört in dem Moment auch nicht, weil die ja auf einem anderen Kanal gerade war. Das heißt, die lässt sich auch nicht auf einem anderen Kanal ansprechen.
Nö, genau. Und dann hatten wir eben gesehen, ok, wenn wir das machen, dann können wir auch sagen, nö, wir unterstützen eigentlich gar keine Verschlüsselung hier. Machen wir bitte ohne weiter, weil der Cyphering wird vom Handset initiiert, auch wieder. Ja, und ab dem Zeitpunkt telefoniert dann plötzlich jemand über deine Basisstation statt über seine.
Das heißt, wenn man weiß, dass jemand DECT verwendet, relativ einfach festzustellen ist, wenn man es nicht schon sowieso weiß, dann braucht man ja nur mal anrufen und nebenbei noch die Antenne sozusagen in die Gegend halten. Dann kann man irgendeine andere starke Antenne machen, macht seine eigene Basisstation, die einfach diese RFPI faked, die auch nicht schwierig rauszukriegen ist, weil die wird ja sowieso die ganze Zeit übertragen und dann bucht sich sein Telefon sozusagen bei einem selbst ein und er telefoniert auf einmal oder sie telefoniert auf einmal einen und dann ändert sich erstmal nichts, wenn man auf der anderen Seite dafür sorgt, dass auch wirklich gewählt und telefoniert wird. Nur halt ausgehende Anrufe. Eingene Anrufe hat man natürlich damit noch nicht.
Die kriegt er dann halt jetzt einfach nicht.
Aber das Handset merkt nichts und schaltet auch noch brav die Krypto ab.
Genau.
Super.
Ja, dachten wir uns auch.
Und da kann man eigentlich auch nichts gegen tun?
Nicht so wirklich, ne, also was man dagegen tun müsste, wäre vonseite des Handsets auszusagen. Authentifizier dich auch bitte mal, Basisstation.
Bist du wirklich derjenige, der vorgibt?
Genau. Doch, das ist vorgesehen, aber das machen eben fast keine Handsets.
Ach, das heißt der Standard sieht das vor?
Korrekt, aber in GAP steht eben drin, dass das übliche Profil für zu Hause nur einseitige Authentifizierung ist.
Es gibt im Standard verschiedene.
Weil ist ja nur zu Hause.
Genau, ist ja nur zu Hause. Wir haben das jetzt noch nicht mit Firmen-Handsets probiert. Wir wissen nicht, ob es dort anders ist. Dort steht es im GAP-Profil drin, dass beidseitig, ja, das könnte man mal machen hier.
Aber das heißt, theoretisch können die Handsets das auch?
Ich weiß es nicht, ob es in der Firmware drin ist. Ich habe bisher da nicht geschaut.
Ihr habt kein Telefon gefunden, das das tut?
Das hat keins forciert.
Aber müsstet ihr nicht auch in der Lage gewesen sein, dieser gefakten Basisstation... Ah, nee, das Handset muss das ja anfordern, sozusagen. Und ihr habt einfach keins gefunden, was das tut?
Genau.
Es gibt aber, gerüchteweise gibt es welche.
Das heißt, eigentlich hätten die Handsets laut Standard die Möglichkeit, sich der Identität ihrer Basisstation zu versichern. Aber keins tut es.
Korrekt.
Weil, wozu auch? Dann müsste ja jemand was Böses im Schilde führen.
Es gibt doch eine Sicherheitsanalyse dazu in den RC-Dokumenten, die relativ amüsant zu lesen ist. Ich werde das jetzt nicht wiedergeben. Interessierte Leute sollten sich die einfach mal...
Amüsant in welcher Hinsicht?
Amüsant in der Hinsicht, dass eben das Risiko ein bisschen falsch eingeschätzt wird.
Auf Basis von...
Auf Basis von, naja, okay, das könnte passieren, aber das macht wohl dann keiner.
Weil, ist ja nur Telefon.
Genau.
Ist ja nur Telefon, ist ja zu Hause, hat ja eh...
Dann müsste jemand bei dir vorbeikommen, überleg mal.
Ja, und wenn man zu Hause ist, dann redet man ja auch nur über alle gut. Und gibt auch seine Pläne nicht Preis.
Das war dann irgendwie der erste Angriff. Und dann haben wir uns eben angefangen, richtig die Krypto anzuschauen. Und das hat angefangen mit dem DSAA.
Warte mal, noch mal kurz zu diesem Fall. Das ist ja jetzt mal so technisch ausgedrückt, quasi so ein Man in the Middle Attacke, oder?
Ja, so einseitig nur, weil ich meine, man ist nicht wirklich in the Middle, sondern man hat den anderen für sich praktisch abgegriffen. In the Middle müsste man noch die andere Seite machen.
Und könnte man denn auch jetzt die eingehenden Anrufe, also kann man sich auch der eigentlichen Basisstation gegenüber als ein bereits autorisiertes Handset... Okay, gut. Gut, dann mach du erst mal weiter.
Ja, und dann haben wir uns eben angefangen, mit der Krypto zu beschäftigen. Und da hat es eben angefangen mit dem DSAA. Das ist eigentlich auch ganz lustig, wie das passiert ist.
Sagen wir nochmal kurz, dass es zwei Krypto-Standards gibt.
Genau, das ist der DECT-Standard Authentication Algorithm und der DECT-Standard Cipher.
Okay, also einmal der, wie autorisiere ich mich, und einmal der, wie verschlüssel ich mich.
Genau, äquivalent dazu bei GSM sind eben zum Beispiel der Comp 128 oder A5 A3 und der A5 als DSC. Also bei GSM ist der Comp 128 die Authentifizierung, was eben jetzt bei DECT-DSAA ist, und A5 die Verschlüsselung, was eben bei DECT-DSC ist. Und angefangen hat die ganze Sache damit, dass irgendwie Masu in dem Treiber nach XORs gekreppt hat. Weil, ich meine, jede Verschlüsselungssoftware verwendet ja irgendwie XORs. Also hat er irgendwie den Treiber disassembliert und hat gekreppt, wo kommt da drin ein XOR vor. Dann dachten einige Leute auf der Mailing-Miste, oh, jetzt haben wir einen Cipher gefunden. Und dann haben wir festgestellt, nee, nicht ganz der Cipher, es ist die Authentifizierung. Aber es ist auch schon mal ein Anfang.
Es gab zwei Stellen im Treiber, wo das drin war. Das eine haben wir relativ schnell rausgekriegt. Das war eine CAC32-Routine.
Den Treiber, den ihr untersucht habt, das war dieser Original-Windows-Treiber von der Comr-Karte.
Und da war eine CAC32-Funktion drin, die verwendet XOR. Das andere konnten wir erstmal nicht identifizieren.
Also für Check-Summen.
Genau. Das andere war halt irgendwas, das kannte man nicht. Das sah auch extrem merkwürdig aus. Und das war irgendwas, was auch nicht Standard war.
Interessanterweise hat es dann auf einen Speicherbereich zugegriffen, der exakt 256 Bytes groß war und der eine Permutation von allen 256 Werten war. Hm, könnte das eine S-Box sein?
Genau.
Eine S-Box, eine Substitutionsbox in der Kryptographie.
Kann man das erklären?
Das kann man einfach erklären. Das ist einfach das, was in der Kryptographie bei einer Blockschiffre nicht Linearität erzeugen soll. Also möglichst zufällig aussehen, naja, mehr oder weniger zufällig aussehen. Wichtig ist es eben, dass es nicht linear ist, diese Tabelle. Und das wird dann mit anderen Komponenten, mit linearen Funktionen kombiniert, die eben Diffusion erzeugen. Und eine S-Box erzeugt eben sogenannte Konfusion. Das sind die beiden Schenchen-Prinzipien, die man...
Okay, das sind die digitale Rauchgranate, damit man ein bisschen Nebel erzeugt, um dies leichter kann zu werden.
Und ja, dann haben wir irgendwie geschaut, diese 256-Bytes, kommen die denn bei uns noch in anderen Firmwares vor? Haben dann mal kurz über andere Firmwares drüber gekreppt und haben festgestellt, oh, die kommen allen vor.
Was tust du, wenn du sagst, du grebst mal durch die Firmware? Also, ich meine, was für einen Vorgang beschreibst du da jetzt wirklich?
Was für einen Vorgang? Ich suche halt nach einer Zeichenkette. In den rohen, binären Code.
Einfach gesucht nach Strings.
Ja, nach binären Strings, in dem Fall. Ja, und die kamen eben allen vor. Und dann haben wir uns eben die Routine, die eben darauf zugegriffen hat, ein bisschen näher angeschaut.
Das heißt, ihr disassembliert den Code, der ja sozusagen für den Prozessor übersetzt ist, schaut euch dann sozusagen im Assembler-Sourcecode an und denkt euch, was ihr da macht.
Genau, haben dann eben dazu eine C-Funktion geschrieben, die das Gleiche macht und haben dann verifiziert mit dem Kernel-Debagger. Ich glaube, das war relativ haarige Arbeit. Das habe ich nicht gemacht, das haben, glaube ich, Erik und Andreas mal im Wochenende gemacht, dass die C-Funktion dann auch wirklich das tut, was wir im Treiber drin haben.
Ja, und dann wirklich OVCR haben wir es verifiziert. Das heißt, wir hatten dann irgendwann mal etwas, was wir für den DECT-Standard Authentication Algorithm gehalten haben. Und wir hatten auch ebenfalls einen Schlüssel dazu. Dann haben wir wirklich mal ausprobiert. Das heißt, Andreas hat bei sich irgendwie mit seinem Sniffer die Kommunikation zwischen dem DECT-Telefon abgefangen. Da hat man eben den Challenge und den Response gesehen. Und den Schlüssel hatten wir eben aus dem Telefon bzw. aus dem Können-Speich heraus kopiert. Dann haben wir halt bei uns das, was wir dann programmiert hatten, ebenfalls laufen gelassen und haben gesehen, dass was wir jetzt als Code haben, das berechnet genau die gleiche Response.
Sehr viel später haben wir dann entdeckt, dass in der Fritz-Box, in diesem Kernel-Modul, diese 256-byte-Namen-S-Box reingekriegt wurde.
Aber nicht in diesen Symbolen sozusagen. Hättet ihr sozusagen auch einfacher haben können.
Hätten wir auch einfacher haben können, aber das ist ja immer so.
Aber spätestens dann wart ihr euch auch sicher, dass ihr jetzt das Richtige gefunden habt.
Ja, das waren wir schon vorher. Es gibt einen Testvektor in dem Security-Standard von DECT und als der dann eben verifiziert hatte, ja.
Okay, also mit anderen Worten, ihr seid durch Reverse-Engineering des Treibers quasi dem eigentlichen Algorithmus der Authentication von DECT auf die Spur gekommen. Das heißt, ihr habt jetzt wirklich den Algorithmus in Source Code implementiert und könnt diesen Authentifizierungscode, der eigentlich total geheim ist, auch sprechen. Wie geheim ist denn der eigentlich? Ich meine, irgend einer muss den ja kennen, sonst gäbe es ja keine Produkte.
Alle DECT-Stack-Hersteller haben den.
Aber wie wird man denn DECT-Stack?
Man geht zur Etsy, zahlt den halt Kohle und sagt, ich will jetzt etwas entwickeln und zeigt eben, dass man das entsprechende Commitment hat. Ich weiß nicht, wie das genau geht, der letzte Schritt.
Und da schreibt er noch ein ziemlich dickes Vertrag, eine NDA, wo man sagt, ich teste da nichts auf Sicherheit, ich gebe das nicht raus und so weiter.
Ich nummeriere jede Kopie von dem Standard durch, die ich habe. Ich stelle sicher, dass irgendwie die ganzen Kopien vom Standard alle zerstört werden, wenn man es nicht mehr braucht und so weiter.
Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt noch, der später in der Geschichte interessant wird. Wir reichen auch keine Patente zu diesen Sachen ein.
Wir patentieren da nichts.
Das wird wichtig, wenn wir zu dem DECT-Standard-Zeitvergleich kommen.
Und wir löschen auch das Gedächtnis aller Mitarbeiter, die wir entlassen haben, die vorher in unserer Abteilung kamen.
Das steht also nicht drin, aber es ist impliziert.
Ich frage mich, wie die das machen.
Ich weiß nicht, aber ich meine, die Geheimhaltung hat eigentlich relativ gut geklappt. Ich meine, uns hat niemand diese Sachen geleakt. Das wäre für uns einfacher gewesen. Aber wir müssen uns die Finger dreckig machen.
Es ist schon interessant, dass das so halbwegs funktioniert. Ich meine, wie lange gibt es den Standard jetzt? 20 Jahre knapp.
Die DECT-Familie ist sehr, sehr klein. Nur ein paar Hersteller, ein paar DECT-Stack-Hersteller, vielleicht fünf. Und von denen haben auch wirklich nur die, die es brauchen, die Informationen, sonst keiner.
Naja, unter anderem noch Leute in der Etsy, Leute beim französischen Geheimdienst und so weiter und so fort. Also das ist auch eine lustige Randgeschichte, die, glaube ich, vor ein paar Jahren mal über einen Heiseticker gegangen ist. Der französische Auslandsgeheimdienst hat eine Schulung gemacht zu dem Thema wie breche ich DECT praktisch. Und das hat die so in ihrem Vorlesungsverzeichnis drin. Das Problem ist natürlich, man muss dazu irgendwie französische Regierungsangestellter mit einer gewissen Geheimhaltungsstufe sein. Ich habe auch mal jemand von den Jungs angesprochen, aber der wollte mir nichts dazu sagen, was sie da genau hatten.
Diese Auslandlication, die kommt jetzt nochmal wann genau zum Spiel? Die kommt sowohl bei dem erstmaligen Einbuchen schon zum Spielen?
Genau, bei der Keyallocation braucht man die. Und bei der Authentifizierung eben von...
Nach dem Einschalten wieder. Das heißt, das ist jetzt sozusagen das Rüstzeug, was man braucht, um eigentlich gegenüber einer Basisstation so zu tun, als wäre man... oder was man sprechen muss, um sich überhaupt erstmal authentifizieren zu können. Aber um...
Eine Sache noch, bei manchen Geräten sieht es so aus, dass du bei jedem Telefonanruf den Algorithmus auch nochmal brauchst. Also wenn du rauswählen willst, müsste das nochmal ablaufen.
Ah, okay.
Ich verstehe. Aber das reicht ja jetzt so alleine erstmal der Algorithmus nicht, um wirklich so zu tun, als wäre man ein anderes Telefon. Dazu braucht man ja noch diesen Key, den man ursprünglich...
Richtig, genau. Und längere Zeit haben wir auf diesen DSA-Art darauf geguckt. Der besteht aus vier Blockschiffen, die relativ ähnlich sind. Da hat Stefan Lux von der Bauhaus-Universität Weimar auch mitgemacht. Und er hat dann einen Angriff gefunden auf die Blockschiffre, die mit einem relativ moderaten Arbeitsfaktor brechbar war, mit relativ wenigen Klartextschiffrotexpaaren. 2 auf 40 war der Aufwand. Wie viele Klartextschiffrotexpaare waren es? Eine Handvolle. 16.
Also Kinderkram.
Ja, ein Hexadezimal halt voll. Das Problem war aber, wir hatten eben vier von diesen blöden Blockschiffen hintereinander geschaltet, relativ seltsam. Und wir kommen nur durch eine durch. Dann habe ich mir noch eingeschaut, okay, ich komme durch eine halbe durch.
Was meinst du damit, du kommst da durch?
Ja, also ich kann die angreifen, praktisch. Also mit zwei auch.
Also das heißt halt, du hast halt irgendwie zwei von denen hintereinander. Und was du halt irgendwie üblicherweise machst bei Krypto ist, du hast halt dann effektiv so einen Blockschiff, hat halt so eine Rundenstruktur. Das heißt, es laufen immer sehr, sehr ähnliche Funktionen immer hintereinander ab. Und bei der Schifffansicht sind es jetzt sechs von diesen Durchgängen. Wenn du zwei Schiffen hintereinander hast, hast du zwölf von diesen Funktionen. Was du halt immer schaust in der Analyse, was passiert dann, wenn ich nur eine von diesen Funktionen laufen lasse? Kann ich es dann angreifen? Wenn ich zwei laufen lasse, kann ich es dann angreifen? Kann ich es angreifen, wenn ich drei laufen lasse und so?
Und angreifen heißt genau was?
Ja, in dem Fall eben, man hat ein Ausgabepaar und man will einen Schlüssel haben.
Genau, und wenn ich das schneller kann als ein Algorithmus, der einfach alle Schlüssel nur durchprobiert, dann ist das ein erfolgreicher Angriff.
Und was uns dann eben auch als erstes damals aufgefallen ist, ist, dass man zwar irgendwie einen 128-Bit-Schlüssel hat, aber die effektive Sicherheit von der ganzen Sache war eben leider nur bei 64-Bit.
Weil wieder 64-Bit einfach Null war oder was?
Null, weil die Verschaltung von den Blogschüffern intern ebenso war, dass man eben die invertieren konnte, wenn man 64-Bit bereits geraten hatte, richtig. Und damit war das dann auf das machbare Niveau praktisch runtergedrückt.
Das heißt, die eigentliche Krypto zumindest der Authentifizierung? Bezieht sich das jetzt nur auf die Authentifizierung?
Also die Verschlüsselung ist sowieso nur 64-Bit. Ja, und dann haben wir, ok, jetzt deine Frage nochmal, wie kann ich mich dann...
Naja, also wir haben ja sozusagen, gleich zu Anfang war ja klar, man kann sich sehr leicht als Basisstation gegenüber dem Handset ausgeben. Aber die nächste Frage ist ja, wie leicht kann man sich als Handset ausgeben gegenüber einer Basisstation? Also kann ich so tun, als wäre ich schon ein bereits angemeldetes Telefon?
Genau, da kommen wir nochmal zur Keyallocation zurück. Und da habe ich mir dann irgendwie eines Nachts mal angeschaut, wie es denn eigentlich aussieht mit dieser Schlüsselgenerierung und wo da die Entropie bei den Zufallszahlen herkommt.
Also die Entropie ist sozusagen die...
Wieviel Schlüsselraum gibt es denn wirklich?
Die Menge an Snort, die da sozusagen mit drin steckt.
Und ja, irgendwie bin ich dann nach einer Stunde fast vom Stuhl gefallen, weil ich gedacht habe, das kann doch nicht sein. Dann habe ich irgendwie geschlafen, am nächsten Morgen nochmal drauf geschaut und dachte, Scheiße, das ist wirklich so. Was dann eben passiert war, dass...
Wie schaut man denn so oft auf Entropie?
Naja, man nimmt vielleicht so ein Disassembler her, eine kleine Firmware her, schaut, wo wird denn da die Keyallocation ausgeführt. Dann schaut man in den Standard rein, okay, was geht denn bei dieser Keyallocation genau mit ein? Dann sieht man, okay, da geht irgendwie 64-Bit-Wert ein, der kommt von der Basisstation. Oh, es kommt nichts von dem Handset, das ist ja viel einfacher. Ich dachte, ich müsste zwei Zufallszahlgeneratoren angreifen, aber ich muss nur einen angreifen. Okay, machen wir weiter. Okay, dann haben wir irgendwie noch eine PIN, aber die kann nur vierstellig sein, 13-Bit gezählt. Ja, und dann eben auf den Zufallszahlgenerator draufgeschaut, auf den ersten, und dann irgendwie gezählt und dachte, es gibt einen 16-Bit-Wert, der da einfließt, es gibt einen 8-Bit-Wert, und das war's. Das heißt also, plötzlich sind wir jetzt von 64-Bit-Sicherheit auf 24 plus 13-Bit-Sicherheit runtergerutscht, und das ist, was durchaus praktisch machbar ist. Der Angriff sieht dann eben so aus, man braucht zwei von diesen Challenge-Response-Paren, und dann kann man das wirklich durchprobieren.
Also, die Computer sind schnell genug, sozusagen. Und das ist nur dieser eine Key, den man sozusagen einfach pro Telefon sozusagen durchrechnen kann.
Korrekt, und wenn man den eben berechnet hat, dann kann man alles.
Das heißt, man hört einmal kurz mit, während dieses Telefon sich an dieser Basisstation anmeldet, oder wieder eingeschaltet. Zweimal. Okay, und dann mit diesen Daten, die man da sozusagen mitgeschnitten hat, oder dass einer was gemerkt hat, weil man muss ja nur eine Antenne im Wald halten, dann rechnet man da drei Stunden dran rum und macht einfach Brut-Force-Rechnung sozusagen alles aus. Und dann hat man den Schlüssel, und wenn man den Algorithmus hat, den hattet ihr ja auch, kann man jetzt im Prinzip dasselbe machen. Das heißt, man kann einfach zur Basisstation gehen und sagen, hallo, ich bin jetzt dieses Telefon, dann sagt die, ha ha ha ha, dann beweist mir das doch mal. Dann nimmt man diesen Schlüssel, den man gerade ausgerechnet hat, spricht DSAA und dann sagt die Basisstation, naja, das ist ja alles sicher.
Passt alles, jetzt darfst du telefonieren oder was auch immer.
Und schon kann ich dem entsprechenden Teilnehmer der Telekommunikation Kosten verursachen.
Oder den Anrufbeantworter auf der Basisstation neu besprechen oder eine Rufumleitung einrichten.
Oder die Türöffner bedienen.
Das mit den Türöffnern, was bitte ist das?
Es gibt von einem namhaften deutschen Hersteller Systeme, es gibt wahrscheinlich auch andere Hersteller, die eben so Gegensprechanlagen für Türen bauen. Und da kann man dann auch über die Tastatur von seinem DECT-Telefon sagen, ok, jetzt bitte öffne mal die Tür.
Die Nachredigiers müssen noch gedreht werden.
Da könnte mal wer zurecht schneiden.
Ja, wenn die nicht schon gedreht werden. Demnächst auf einer Überwachungskamera near you. Genau. Oh weia. Ich meine, das ist ja interessant. Viele Leute verlassen sich bei DECT, DECT hat auch immer so ein bisschen diesen Nimbus von, naja, das ist ja verschlüsselt. Aber jetzt merkt man, das bricht eigentlich alles ganz schön zusammen. Die Krypto ist nicht besonders stark, zumindest den ersten Teil. Den zweiten Teil wissen wir jetzt wahrscheinlich gleich auch noch was zu sagen.
Da hauptsächlich gar nicht vorhanden.
Man sollte vielleicht noch eine Sache dazu sagen, es hört sich jetzt an, als wäre das jetzt einfach nur ein Beispiel gewesen. Aber natürlich, wenn man sich einmal so einen blöden Zufall als Zahlgenerator angeschaut hat, dann denkt man, naja, komm, der andere Hersteller kann es besser. Dann schaut man sich den anderen Hersteller an, dann sieht man, hey, die verwenden nicht 24-bit Entropie, die verwenden 12-bit Entropie. Toll!
Ach so, inwieweit ist denn das jetzt herstellerspezifisch?
Das ist komplett herstellerspezifisch.
Das heißt, dieses Key rausfinden ist jetzt nicht generell alle DECT-Systeme, sondern zumindest diese eine Implementierung.
Derzeitig haben wir drei verschiedene Implementierungen.
Aber wenn man jetzt, sagen wir mal, zum Beispiel Siemens, die ja so mit ihren Gigaset-Produkten doch ich weiß nicht, wie hoch der Marktanteil ist, aber er ist, glaube ich, signifikant, dann kann man schon davon ausgehen, dass da jetzt nicht so sehr viele unterschiedliche Herangehensweisen an die Key-Generationen-Generierung existieren.
Ich glaube, es könnten zwei Generationen davon existieren. Ich habe die Neue davon.
Zwei nur. Das ist nicht viel.
Es könnte sein, dass es mehr gibt, aber ich gehe derzeitig von zwei aus.
Okay.
Bei der Neuen braucht der Angriff halt auf dem Laptop ungefähr eine Sekunde, oder?
Das ist nicht ganz korrekt. Also ich meine, das hängt noch davon ab, wie viel, wie viel, also ob man den kompletten Pin-Space durchraten muss.
Ach so, wenn du eine FPGA-Karte drin hast im Laptop, meine ich. Wenn ich eine FPGA abgeleite, dann kriegt man den kompletten Pin-Space in einer Sekunde für den Fall, dass die Pin-Standard-Pin ist 0000, dann sind wir im Millisekunden-Bereich.
Aber da wir auch gute Cryptografen sind, können wir natürlich auch Rainbow-Tables dafür bauen. Das heißt also, wir brauchen auch keinen FPGA. Wir machen das einmal vorhin ein und dann sind eben diese ganzen, also GALOBS 24 oder 12-Bit oder 18 oder auch 30-Bit Entropie sind, die uns da der Zufallszahlengenerator beschert. Dann ist das alles essig. Dann haben wir eben hier nicht ganz.
Also Rainbow-Tables sind sozusagen vorberechnete.
Genau, dann haben wir eben eine externe Platte und dann können wir da drin...
Die liegen allerdings dann auf Platte und wenn du halt eine FPGA-Karte im Rechner hast, die es vielleicht in 3 Millisekunden schafft, Vergleich zu einer Platte, da muss ich halt auch wiederum den Plattenkopf bewegen. Das dauert vielleicht 10 Millisekunden.
Na wie groß sind denn die Daten dann?
Naja, also ich meine ein paar hundert Megabyte hatte ich mal durchgerechnet für einen der Zufallszahlengenerator.
Da brauchen wir heutzutage keine Festplatte mehr für.
Ja, aber es können auch durchaus ein paar Gigabyte werden.
Ja, aber da braucht man auch keine Festplatte.
Ja, kann auch auf dem SSD.
Oder auf dem USB-Stick könnte man dann vielleicht so gleichfertig als Produkt verkaufen.
USB-Stick könnte eventuell ein bisschen zu langsam sein. Aber wie gesagt, das ist auch etwas, was man über Torrens dann irgendwie durch die Gegend pusten kann. Aber das wollen wir glaube ich nicht machen. Also wenn andere Leute sowas machen, dann...
Aber kurz, bevor wir dann weiter machen mit der Krypto, also Türen, Telefone.
Ja und Verkehrsmanagementsysteme.
Verkehrsmanagementsysteme?
Ja, ja, so Ampeln grün schalten.
Ampeln? Oder rot. Mit dem Krankenwagen halt so schneller.
Oh nein, Straßenbahn Prioritätsschalter und ein bisschen auch noch oder was?
Ich weiß nicht, also wie gesagt, England hat eben Ampelsysteme. Die werden von Siemens Traffic hergestellt. Die gibt es ganz schön auch irgendwo in Deutschland. Das müssen wir mal schauen.
Das heißt, wenn man da so ein bisschen den Krankenwagen hinterherfährt und ein paar Daten sammelt, dann könnte man unter Umständen bevorzugte Behandlungen erfahren, den Verkehr?
Ja, den Straßenverkehr, ja. Aber muss man auch gar nicht, weil die Ampeln kommunizieren auch untereinander und die haben auch eine erhöhte Sendeleistung meines Wissens.
Die Ampeln kommunizieren untereinander?
Ampel auf der einen Seite. Ich bin jetzt grün. Sagt der Ampel auf der anderen Seite, du bist jetzt bitte rot.
Aber sind dann die Ampeln so Handsets oder sind die Ampeln Basisstationen, die sich unterhalten?
Das weiß ich derzeit noch nicht. Wir kriegen ein paar Module demnächst zugeschickt.
Also ich gehe mal von Handsets aus.
Und wer ist dann die Basisstation?
Vielleicht irgendeine übergeordnete Einheit.
Können auch Handsets mit Handsets?
Ja, es gibt auch ein Modi, um ohne Basisstationen zu kommunizieren, DECT.
Das heißt, es gibt sozusagen in DECT auch so Peer-to-Peer. Und wie funktioniert das dann? Müssen die sich dann auch irgendwie...
Also ich habe mich bisher nicht angeschaut. Es steht im Standard drin, aber...
Ich habe jetzt noch nichts in der Richtung an Hardware gesehen, nur im Standard kurz drüber gelesen, aber nicht weiterbeachtet.
Aber wie gesagt, da ist noch ein Forschungsfeld da.
Okay, also auch hier gibt es sozusagen die Möglichkeiten, sich noch mal kreativ mit einzubringen in das Bild.
Das Ding, was wir bisher noch nicht gesehen haben, ist medizinisches Equipment, etwas über DECT-Communizierung. Ich hoffe, das gibt es doch nicht.
Ich schwänze, das gibt es.
So, und das war es jetzt schon? Oder habt ihr euch den Cipher dann auch noch angeschaut?
Den Cipher haben sich ursprünglich erstmal die Hardware-Reversing-Leute angeschaut. Da gab es dann einige...
Wer sind denn die Hardware-Reversing?
Das ist Starbucks, Carsten Nohl und eben in Zusammenarbeit mit FlyLogic. Und Masu war an der Sache auch beteiligt.
Das ist ja das Team, das sich um Mifare schon gekümmert hat. Auch hier gibt es schon das passende Chaos Radio Express, was wahrscheinlich schon jeder kennt, weil das gerade irgendwie auf dem Weg ist, die populärste Sendung bei Chaos Radio Express zu sein. Der Mifare-Hack, wo die Techniken wie die Chips schön auseinandergeschabt wurden. Kam denn diese Technologie bei euch auch zum Einsatz?
Ja, aber irgendwann gab es Probleme mit der weiteren Analyse, weil Leitungen laut Starbuck seltsam verschaltet waren. Und irgendwann ist mir Geduld ausgegangen. Und wir hatten festgestellt, dass dieses Chipset, das wir hatten, dass das einige sehr, sehr nette Features im Befehlssatz hat. Es gab dann nämlich so Kommandos wie DLDK und DWRS. Und wir haben keine Dokumentation für dieses Chipset. Wir hatten nur einen Assembler. Den hat Andreas gefunden.
Den haben wir dann zu diesem Assembler erst mal umgebaut und hatten daraus auch die NANONIX zu den OP-Code. Das war auch alles, was wir zu dem Assembler hatten.
Von welchem Chip redet ihr denn jetzt noch mal?
Von dem SC-Versinn.
Also von diesem eigentlichen, der auf dieser Common-Air-Karte wieder raufgesetzt wird.
Dieser Chip hat eben einen sogenannten Dedicated Instruction Prozessor, mit dem sich Andreas sehr intensiv auseinandergesetzt hat. Und für den gibt es eben auch Firmware. Dafür hatten wir unterschiedliche Firmwares und haben uns angeschaut, welche Kommandos kommen in den Firmwares vor, die verschlüsseln, die in den anderen Firmwares nicht vorkommen. Und da hat es dann eben herausgestellt, hm, D-underscore sind Befehle, die eben in den Firmwares vorkommen, die verschlüsseln. Dann haben wir gesehen, es gibt da so komische Sequenzen, ein DLDK, dann wartet er irgendwie für 39 Takte und dann macht er nochmal ein DLDK und irgendwie seltsam. Und eines Nachts oder eines Nachmittags habe ich dann mal wieder gegoogelt nach DSC, war frustriert und habe dann irgendwie mal die Google-Patentsuche aufgemacht und nach ein paar Minuten einen Freuden-Schrei ausgestoßen, weil es gibt wirklich Leute, die sind so blöd und patentieren wirklich Sachen, wo der NDA wirklich sagt explizit, du darfst es nicht patentieren.
Und du musst es geheim halten.
Das war zum Beispiel Alcatel. Die haben nämlich ein schönes Patent dazu veröffentlicht, wo drin beschrieben ist, dass diese Stromschiffre LFSR-basiert ist, dass die LFSRs Längen von 17, 19, 21, 23 haben, dass die Stromschiffre irregular gekloppt ist, 2, 3. Dann sind sie natürlich nicht darauf eingegangen, wie die Feedback-Taps aussehen, aber sie haben uns erzählt, es gibt eine Pre-Cypher-Phase, die hat irgendwie 40 Schritte. Das hat eine Korrelation zu diesen 39 Takten.
Also Alcatel hat sozusagen gegen das NDA des DECT-Standards verstoßen. Doppelverstoßen. Aber wie können die denn überhaupt auf die id.com etwas zu patentieren, was sie gar nicht erfunden haben?
Sie haben eine Performance-Optimierung dafür erfunden. Sie haben gesagt, wir können jetzt dreimal schneller.
Und dazu mussten sie natürlich beschreiben, was sie dort beschleunigen.
Genau.
Also das heißt, sie haben einmal die Hälfte ihres geheimen Industriestandards, für die sie in NDA unterzeichnet haben, in eine öffentliche Patentschrift reingehauen und BMNDA stand noch drin, du sollst nicht patentieren.
Zumindest in der aktuellen Version des NDAs, wie ich es kenne. Kann auch sein, dass die Etsy danach einmal ausgerastet ist und hat NDA nochmal geändert.
Haben die da jetzt schon offiziell irgendwie den... Nö, weiß ich nicht.
Also ob wir jetzt irgendwie im netten schon am Klo putzen sind, wissen wir nicht.
Es war ein spanisches Patent, was glaube ich 94 gefeilt wurde. Und dann irgendwie...
Oh je, nach 94 Krise jetzt auch noch eine Patentkrise.
Aber es ist hervorragend.
Aber du hast dich gefreut. Weil du hast jetzt sozusagen relevante Rahmendaten über die Funktionsweise.
Genau, und dann diese 40 Takte von dem Precyphering, die haben eben mit diesen 39 Takten in der Firmware korreliert und dann wussten wir, okay, da wird ein Key geladen. Und dann haben wir festgestellt, es gibt ein Kommando write state und es gibt ein Kommando read state. Und damit können wir...
Auf dem Chip.
Genau, damit können wir in den Speicher, den wir vom Host auslesen können, den internen Zustand der Stromschiffe speichern, also die LFSRs. Und was dann angefangen hat, hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Wir konnten nämlich die Stromschiffe Single-Stepen. Das heißt, wir konnten durch einzelne Zustände durchgehen der Stromschiffe. Und damit haben wir dann im ersten Schritt die Feedback-Taps rausbekommen. Die waren, glaube ich, Starbucks bereits bekannt.
Ich muss noch mal durchfragen. Feedback-Taps sind was?
Also es gibt eine weit verbreitete Konstruktionstechnik für Stromschiffe. Die stammt aus den späten 60ern.
Also Stromschiffe sind also generell Verschlüsselung von Datenströmen, ne?
Ja, also im offiziellen deutschen Dienstsprachgebrauch heißt das auch Flussschiffe statt Stromschiffe. Also wenn man mit BSI-Leuten spricht, dann heißt das immer Flussschiffe. Und das ist eine Schiffre, die eben bitweise meist arbeitet und nicht blockweise, weil man will eben mit Sprachdaten verschlüsseln und wenn ein einzelnes Bit kippt, will man das auch.
Also Versus-Blockschiffre, wo es eben auf Blockbasis passiert.
Genau, wenn man nicht das komplett an N-Bytes umfällt, sondern eben nur an Bit. Ja, und LFSRs sind lineare Schieberegister im Deutschen. Und wenn man diese in Hardware implementiert, dann hat man sogenannte Feedback-Taps. Das heißt, man hat so eine Kette von Flip-Flops. Und man hat ein bisschen Logik zwischen den Flip-Flops. Das heißt, man greift zwischen den Flip-Flops was ab. Und was passiert? In jedem Takt schiebt man praktisch den Inhalt dieser Flip-Flops eins nach rechts und dann nach links, je nachdem, wie man das implementiert hat. Wendet eine Funktion an, die eben von manchen dieser Flip-Flops was abgreift. Und am Ende eben ganz rechts oder ganz links wieder reinschiebt. Warum man das so macht, ist, weil man eben für diese linearen Schieberegister in den 60ern mal gezeigt hat, wenn man die mathematisch beschreibt mit Polynomen über GF2, dann kann man für gewisse Polynome, nämlich für irreducible Polynome, zeigen, dass die Länge der Ausgabesequenz von so einem linearen Schieberegister maximal ist. Das heißt also, wenn man eben jetzt zum Beispiel ein 19-bitiges Schieberegister hat, dann ist die Ausgabelänge, bis sich die Sache wiederholt, meine Sequenz, es sind eben 2 hoch 19 minus 1 Bits. Aber man nimmt heutzutage nicht nur eines dieser LFS-Rs, sondern man muss mehrere nehmen, weil wenn man eben nur eins hat, dann ist es linear und dann ist es einfach anzugreifen. Und dann, was eben in diesem DSC gemacht wurde, die wurden eben noch irregulär getaktet. Das heißt also, es ist nicht klar, dass immer das Register 1 um zwei Takte nach vorne gezählt wird, sondern es kann auch sein, dass mal um drei Takte nach vorne gezählt wird. Das wird entschieden anhand von Inhalten der anderen Register. Aber wir waren eben in der Lage, zum einen diese Feedback-Taps zu bestimmen, dadurch, dass wir diese Zustände in den Speicher zurück schreiben konnten, sagen konnten, okay, jetzt machen wir einen Tag, jetzt machen wir zwei Takte, drei Takte und so weiter und so fort. Und im zweiten Schritt, nachdem wir diese Feedback-Taps hatten, konnten wir die Clock-Control, also das, was eben sagt, zählt jetzt zwei oder drei vor in den Registern, konnten wir analysieren. Eben auch wieder, indem wir Schritte einzeln durchgegangen sind. Dann haben wir uns angeschaut, welche Bits, wenn wir jetzt unterschiedlichen Zustand in den Speicher schreiben, also immer ein Bit gekippt, dann Endtakte nach vorne gezählt und geschaut, was passiert, wenn man dieses Bit nicht gekippt hat. Und dann kriegt man eben so eine Sequenz von Bits, die einem sagt, okay, jetzt waren diese Bits an der Clocking-Entscheidung an dieser Register beteiligt. Und im zweiten Schritt kann man dann eben daraus berechnen, wenn man das mehrmals macht, was für eine Funktion das war, die auf diesen Bits eben zu der Clocking-Entscheidung geführt hat. Das heißt, wir haben derzeit, wie kamen wir in DSC, fast komplett, was uns fehlt, ist die Output-Funktion. Das heißt, von jedem Register wird noch was abgegriffen. Das ist meistens das rechtmöglichste oder das linksmöglichste Bit. Dann wird eine bursche Funktion auf diesen Bits angewandt. Und im Fall vom DSC, das wissen wir auch wieder aus dem Patent, gibt es noch einen Speicherbit, was eben den letzten Zustand hält, der nochmal in diese bursche Funktion mit einfließt. Aber alles in allem gehen wir davon aus, dass das nochmal irgendwie so eine Nacht an Arbeit ist, das fertig zu machen. Aber wir hatten bisher einfach die Zeit dazu nicht.
Wie viel Prozent des Wissens hast du jetzt aus diesem Patent herausgezogen? Und wie viel Prozent habt ihr euch selber jetzt schon dazu gedichtet? Und wie viel fehlt noch?
Also ich würde sagen, 40 Prozent haben wir aus dem Patent.
40.
40, ja. 40 Prozent kommen nochmal aus dem Single-Stapping. Und die 10 Prozent, nein, die 20, die waren noch auf 20. Dann sagen wir, 50 haben wir aus dem Single-Stapping. Und 10 Prozent fehlen uns.
Und 10 Prozent müssen wir noch aus der Nacht herausmelken.
Genau, aber die kriegen wir im Endeffekt dadurch heraus, dass wir einmal ein verschlüsseltes Telefonat vernünftig mitsniffen und dann eben die handvoll Möglichkeiten, die es noch gibt, durchgehen. Weil ich meine, wir können die Schlüssel, mit denen wir verschlüsselt haben, können wir sehen, bei der Fritzbox. Und den verschlüsselten Text haben wir. Das heißt, wir gehen dann durch mit den unterschiedlichen Möglichkeiten, die die Stromschiffre eben noch hat, schauen, was da entschlüsselt, und schauen dann halt eben, ob das Sinn macht, ob irgendwie vernünftige Sprache da rauskommt oder ob ein C-Kanal was vernünftiges da rauskommt.
Das heißt, es ist durchaus absehbar, dass die vollständige Funktionsweise des DSC auch erkennbar ist. Lässt sich denn jetzt dann sozusagen auch schon absehen, dass es auch offensichtliche Schwächen gibt? Oder ist das noch unklar?
Das ist derzeit noch unklar. Schwächen untersuchen können wir schon ohne die Combiner-Funktion. Die Combiner-Funktion ist nur ein kleiner Stolperstein, den wir dann brauchen, um das Ganze später mal aufzuschreiben. Also zumindestens, nachdem, wie ich derzeit die Situation einschätze, gehe ich nämlich davon aus, dass die Combiner-Funktion komplett linear ist. Es gibt nichts, was auf etwas anderes hindeutet. Der DSC sieht sehr, sehr ähnlich aus wie der A51, der bei GSM verwendet wird.
Und der ist ja auch schon...
Moment, aber er ist stärker erstaunlicherweise, weil der interne Zustand größer ist. Bei dem A51 ist er nur 64 Bit und in unserem Fall ist er 80 Bit. Wir hatten uns erst gefreut, weil wenn man eben nur das Patent vor Augen hat, dann sieht es aus wie ein A52. Aber beim A52, was zu dieser starken Schwäche führt, dass man die Clock-Control nur in einem Register hat, das ist eben beim DSC definitiv nicht so. Das haben wir festgestellt. Da ist die Clock-Control von drei, von vier Registern abhängig.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall verwandt und man weiß schon, in welcher Domain man sich befindet.
Und es gibt eine Sache, die mir an der Stelle Hoffnung macht. Bei GSM ist die Anzahl der Clock-Entscheidungen, bis man das erste Bit an Output generiert, 111. Das ist die sogenannte Pre-Cyphering-Phase beim DSC oder in der Kryptographie nennt man das auch Blank Rounds.
111?
Ja, 111. Und bei DECT sind es nur 40 Clocking-Entscheidungen, bis das erste Output-Bit rausfällt.
Was dafür spricht, dass es an der Stelle wieder ein bisschen schwächer ist?
Genau, was eben dafür spricht, dass da eventuell was machbar ist.
Und dann ist Schluss. Also, ich meine, das heißt, es gibt aber jetzt sozusagen noch keine Attacke auf diesen DSC.
Nein, aber ich arbeite daran.
Okay, und ihr seid dann sozusagen, ihr seid besser lauter, das merkt man sowieso. Hier ist Aufbruchstimmung, ehrlich gesagt. Ich meine, das würde dann bedeuten, das sieht sozusagen so aus, als ob man kurz davor steht, dass man eigentlich überall einfach nur noch die Antenne hochhalten muss und man kann einfach etwas was, selbst wenn es verschlüsselt ist, was es schon häufig nicht ist, dass man es dann auch noch...
Naja, ich meine, ob jetzt der Angriff, den ich hoffe zu finden, ob der praktisch ist, wirklich, ist eine andere Sache. Ich meine, Kulturgrafik gibt es natürlich auch Angriffe.
Was wird denn eigentlich mit diesem DSC wirklich verschlüsselt? Alles, die vollständige Kommunikation einschließlich dieses C-Kanals oder ist es nur Sprache?
Der C-Kanal wird mit verschlüsselt.
Nur der C-Kanal und das B-Feld, also die Sprache.
Und diese Tür, von der wir da gesprochen haben, benutzt die Verschlüsselung?
Das läuft über den C-Kanal, sehr wahrscheinlich. Sehr wahrscheinlich.
Okay, weil sonst wäre es ja wirklich grob fahrlässig.
Wobei die Verschlüsselung vom Handset eingeschaltet wird und da der Knopf auf dem Handset ist, ist das eigentlich unerheblich, ob das verschlüsselt ist oder nicht. Wir können der Station sagen, unser Handset gehört jetzt dazu. Also wenn wir den UAK rausbekommen haben.
Wenn wir den UAK haben für so ein Ding, dann ist es natürlich sowieso game over. Also das muss man vielleicht an der Stelle nochmal dazu sagen. Wenn man den UAK hat, also User Authentication Key, dann kann man auch alle weiteren Dynamic Cypher Keys bestimmen. Das heißt, man braucht sich den DSC eigentlich nicht mehr anzuschauen. Also sicherheitstechnisch. Weil man muss nur den DSC haben, um zu entschlüsseln. Aber man muss ihn nicht mehr brechen, weil man hat ja den Verschlussungsschlüssel schon rausgebekommen.
Das brauchen wir eigentlich nichtmals, weil der ist eingebaut. Also eigentlich in jeder DECT-Hardware sitzt der in Hardware im Chip. So gesehen können wir den einfach verwenden, ohne wirklich zu kennen.
Es gibt nur einen, oder was?
Ja, im DSC gibt es nur einen Rhythmus.
Ach so, den eigenen Rhythmus.
Interessanterweise sieht der DECT-Standard aber an der Stelle vor, dass sowohl der DSAA als auch der DSC austauschbar sind. In manchen Publikationen von der Etsy heißt nämlich der DSC auch DSC1. Aber es gibt de facto keinen anderen derzeitig.
Jetzt sieht das ja eigentlich relativ böse aus. De facto bedeutet, dass das eigentlich kein DECT-basiertes System mehr als sicher gelten kann.
Vielleicht, falls irgendwer es sinnvoll wirklich implementiert hat.
Genau, ich wollte mal sagen, die einzige Möglichkeit, die ich so sehe, ist, dass man zumindest dieses Telefon verlangt, Authentifizierung der Basisstation Feature, dass man das mal benutzt.
Und Verschlußung verlangen.
Aber natürlich hat heutzutage eigentlich keine DECT-Hardware, die ich kenne, irgendeine Möglichkeit des Software-Updates, oder?
Ich habe hier einen Gigaset SL74, das kann man flashen. Aber das ist eines der sehr, sehr wenigen Geräte und das habe ich auch nur exakt aus dem Grund, weil man es flashen kann. Weil es die Möglichkeit hat, dass man das EEPROM über das Pinpad ändert. Das ist hilfreich, wenn man zum Beispiel einen UAK und eine IPUI über das Pinpad eingeben will. Aber die Funktionalität ist noch nicht ganz fertig.
Aber ich meine, de facto die allermeiste Consumer-Hardware, die einfach da draußen rumsteht, hat ja noch nicht mal eine Schnittstelle, über die man irgendwelche Daten hineinführen kann.
Das ist nicht ganz korrekt. Wenn ihr mal euer DECT-Telefon aufmacht auf der Rückseite und ins Batteriefach schaut, dann seht ihr ein paar Kontakte. Immer.
Fast immer.
Oder auf der Platine, wo man das Gehäuse öffnet.
Aber effektiv Batteriedeckel draußen, dann sind da meistens ein paar Löcher drin. Und wenn man dann auf die Platine guckt, das sind da ganz dicke Lötpunkte, sodass man da mit so einem DIPA-Connector draufgehen kann.
Bei manchen kann man darüber das EEPROM schreiben. Es gibt allerdings auch Telefone, die darüber einen JTAG nach außen führen. Und wenn man eben so ein Telefon mit einem JTAG hat, dann kann man, wenn das Telefon eben einen neueren Chip hat, der eben Flash hat statt ROM, kann man die Software ändern.
Also JTAG ist dieser Standard-Debugging-Connector für Hardware-Entwicklung.
Genau.
Aber trotzdem, das ist natürlich absolut unrealistisch zu glauben, dass das in irgendeiner nahen Zukunft alle etablierten Systeme...
Ich meine, für die andere Geschichte mit den Zufallszahlgeneratoren ist es die Basisstation, die wichtig ist. Das kann man bei manchen Sachen noch fixen, wenn es eben ein Firmware-Update erlaubt. Aber bei dem Großteil der Basisstationen hilft es halt einfach nur wegwerfen und neu kaufen. Und das ist halt verdammt bitter.
Wobei die Neuen jetzt ja auch nicht sicher sind.
Ja, richtig, also wegwerfen und irgendwas Vernünftiges in einem Jahr oder so neu kaufen müsste es dann heißen.
Wegwerfen und Kabel benutzen.
Jetzt habt ihr ja einen Vortrag gehalten, habe ich schon erwähnt, auf dem Kongress. Habt ihr denn schon irgendwelche Reaktionen jetzt von begeisterten Zuhörern und Medien, die sich schon mal abgesehen, erhalten?
Wir haben einen Equipment-Hersteller aus Deutschland, der sich irgendwie beim Erik und bei mir gemeldet hat. Wir haben uns darauf zurück gemeldet bei denen, aber da kam nichts mehr, das hat uns ein bisschen gewundert. Also erst wollten sie uns Kontakt aufnehmen, aber dann kommt nichts zurück. Das ist ein bisschen seltsam.
Also ihr seid durchaus gesprächsbereit, aber Sie sind alle noch nicht aus dem Weihnachtsurlaub zurück.
Ich habe heute dann mal gedacht, ich melde mal den Chair der Etsy Sage Working Group an. Das ist die Security Algorithm Experts Group. Weil lustigerweise gibt es einen Bericht von denen aus dem Jahr 2007, wo sie einen Jahresbericht abgeliefert haben. Und da haben sie gesagt, ja, im Jahre 2006 haben wir eine Studie zur Sicherheit von DECT durchgeführt. Der nächste Satz war dann, wir müssen mal eine neue Working Group machen und neue Algorithmen dafür bauen. Sie haben das nicht als direkten Schluss aus der Studie dargestellt, aber wir bauen da was Neues, wahrscheinlich AES-basiert. Die Entwicklungen von der EZI sind weitestgehend öffentlich einsehbar. Und ich habe keine einzige Working Group gefunden, die sich derzeit damit beschäftigt hat. Das heißt, es sind zwei Jahre vergangen und nichts passiert.
Das heißt, es sieht danach aus, als ob jetzt auch erstmal ein paar Public Hacks stattfinden müssen, bevor die Hersteller gerade wirklich aufwachen. Also neue Durchsagen im ICE und selbstöffnende Garagentüren. Gibt es noch irgendwie schöne Beispiele?
Also die Ampel-Grünschaltung wollen wir nicht wirklich. Lass das bitte.
Nein, nein, das ist keine gute Idee. Das habe ich auch vorhin alles nicht gesagt. Das war nur hypothetisch.
Rein hypothetisch, ja. Wie gesagt, also ich hatte mich heute mit Herrn Babbage, dem Etsy Sage Working Group Chair in Verbindung gesetzt und habe ihm gesagt, wahrscheinlich hast du was davon gehört, dass wir da so einen Vortrag gehalten haben beim CCC. Und es gibt da so ein paar Probleme mit den Random Number Generators. Und ich würde ganz gerne die Hersteller informieren, aber das sind viele und ich müsste halt wissen, wie. Weil das Problem ist, dass eben diese Fehler systematisch sind und dass es auch nur sehr, sehr wenige DECT-Stack-Hersteller gibt, aber sehr, sehr viele Endgeräteverkäufer. Und ich nicht nur mit den Herstellern praktisch von den Handsets oder von den Basisstationen in Verbindung treten muss an der Stelle, sondern mit den Stack-Herstellern. Und da habe ich eben keine Kontakte hin.
Und auch gegebenenfalls von denen, die die Chips machen, oder?
Ja, das sind meist auch die Stack-Hersteller. Aber es gibt einen Fall, da ist es etwas anders gelagert, dass wirklich ein sehr, sehr weit verbreiteter Stack ist von einer Firma, die nur Stacks herstellt und die haben ein Problem. Und die Antwort von ihm war dann, nein, habe ich noch nicht. Danke für die Information. Meine Kollegen haben mir nur erzählt, was für uns hier von Vodafone relevant ist. Ja, okay, das war dann der Aufwachruf. Aber er hat mir jetzt zugesichert, dass er bei der DECT-Standard Working Group mal was triggert und dass eben die Herstellerkontakte hergestellt werden.
Ja, vielleicht hilft auch so ein bisschen die Kundenbeschwerde. Ich denke, dass einige Zuhörer jetzt hier vielleicht auch dabei sind, denen jetzt erst so richtig klar wird, dass sie da gerade in ihrer Firma oder sonstigen Organisationen unter Umständen ein Sicherheitsproblem haben oder auch ein Kostenproblem haben, ein potenzielles. Also das kann ja alle möglichen Implikationen haben, wenn irgendjemand einfach mal eben die Basisstation übernimmt oder eben so tut, irgendein Telefon zu sein. Also Sicherheitssysteme haben wir ja schon hier, Türöffner usw. Was da noch alles mit drin ist, das kann wirklich weitreichende Folgen haben. Und ich denke, da ist es mal sehr angemessen, wenn man morgen mal den Telefonhörer in die Hand nimmt und vielleicht mal den, wo dann so ein Kabel hinten aus dem Telefon rauskommt, und mal den Hersteller der eigenen Telefonanlage anruft und mal fragt, was denn ihre Antwort auf diese Frage ist. Und die Frage lautet, ist denn das alles noch sicher?
Es gibt natürlich noch weiter sehr, sehr hypothetische Szenarien, die aber auch lustig werden könnten, weil es hat bisher, glaube ich, noch niemand einen DECT-Standard gefasst.
Also Fuzzing ist so, man hält mal die Kanone drauf und guckt mal, was umfällt.
Genau, weil es gibt ja auch durchaus so integrierte Produkte, wie diese Fritzbox, von der ich vorhin sprach. Ich weiß es nicht, also das ist jetzt irgendwie ein Stack, der seit zehn Jahren entwickelt wurde meistens, der im Kernspace ist und der sicherheitstechnisch nicht so wirklich toll aussieht.
Es könnte da durchaus Probleme geben.
Sprich Buffer-Overflows und ähnliche Geschichten.
Das heißt, es könnte durchaus auch weitere Angriffsvekte auf so integrierte Systeme sein. Oder mal komplett eine Telefonanlage über DECT.
Oder durch die Stadt fahren und die Hälfte der Telefone zum Absturz bringen.
Ja, aber das ist kontraproduktiv.
Dann schon lieber ON.
Was relativ einfach ist im Protokoll, ist dieses Klingeln lassen. Das wäre natürlich auch noch eine Möglichkeit. Dafür gibt es noch keine fertige Software, die einfach mal alles in der Umgebung klingeln lässt.
Also mit dem Paging.
Genau. Was aktuell im Netz ist, das tut nur passiv. Jedes Telefongespräch in der Umgebung aufzeichnen. Das ist prinzipiell nett.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob du das als Amateurfunka so empfehlen solltest. Man macht sich natürlich ein bisschen strafbar.
Das Paging ist tatsächlich ein unglaublicher Poltergeist-Effekt. Da muss man sich auch schon über den mentalen Zustand eines Stadtteils Gedanken machen, um dann wirklich an die Telefone anfangen zu können.
Du bist doch bei Blinken-Lights. Du kennst das ja, wenn man vor so einem Hochhaus steht, so 20 immer 20 Fenster, alles dunkel, und dann drückt man so ein Knopf auf ein Knöpfchen, und dann werden dann so Fenster hell. Prinzipiell mit einer DECT-Karte kann man das nachts um 3 Uhr bestimmt machen.
Vielleicht kann man auch mal was komponieren. Schau mal, es gibt unterschiedliche Klingeltöne. Aua.
Das ist so ein bisschen die Büchse der Pandora. Und es ist wirklich schwierig. Das ist natürlich jetzt auch wieder so eine Sache. Kann man vielleicht auch noch mal kurz drüber reden jetzt so zum Ende, wie das so mit der Verantwortung des analysierenden Kryptografen ist. Ihr habt da ja auch schon ganz schön das DECT hinzutragen.
Na ja, ich meine, an der Stelle ist es so, dass die Hersteller bisher immer gesagt haben, ja, ja, das ist alles sicher. Wir alle setzen aber DECT wirklich selbst ein. Und wenn mir jemand sagt, das ist sicher und mir gleichzeitig sagt, ne, aber die Algorithmen kriegst du nur unter NDA und den darfst du nicht haben, weil du willst ja kein Equipment herstellen, du willst es ja anschauen, dann bin ich da ein bisschen allergisch. Dann will ich das genauer wissen. Und ja, das ist wahrscheinlich dann auch, wie ich dazu gekommen bin, wie wir anderen eben dazu gekommen sind. Ich sehe die Verantwortung eigentlich so, dass ich meiner Verantwortung voll gerecht geworden bin. Ich habe mir gesagt, da gibt es Sicherheitslücken. Und verdammt nochmal, ihr müsst dann nachbessern. Wenn ich es nicht mache, gibt es ganz bestimmt jemand anders, der es macht und der vielleicht nicht ganz so höhere Interessen verfolgt. Also ich meine, wir hatten dann irgendwie das Szenario mal durchgespielt, was man mit so einem, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht sollte man es doch nicht erzählen, sonst kommerzialisiert das jemand. Also man kann sich sehr, sehr böse Szenarien vorstellen, wenn man zum Beispiel diese UAKs bestimmt, um an Geld zu kommen. Oh ja.
Weil wer ruft wen an und sagt, ist okay und so weiter.
Nein, man denkt doch auch mal vielleicht an so Paynummern. Wenn man einen Bus hat, der so einen Laptop unter die Unterseite, so einen Linienbus mit einem Laptop drunter geklebt, der quer durch die Stadt fährt und überall mal einen Telefonruf absetzt, ist es sehr, sehr schwer nachvollziehbar, was da genau passiert ist.
Außer, dass man vielleicht feststellt, dass ein kompletter Stadtteil jetzt irgendwie bei Ruf mich an aufgelaufen ist. Was natürlich ein bisschen unwahrscheinlich ist, aber wenn man das halt so halbwegs, na ja, etwas randomisierter vorgeht, dann ist es natürlich nicht mehr so ohne Weiteres festzustellen.
Ja, oder man nimmt einen UPS-Wagen.
Beziehungsweise, es gibt ja auch Organisationen, die jetzt nicht so genau nachschauen, wofür sie eigentlich wirklich ihre Telefonkohle zahlen, solange es nicht über so ein gewisses Auffallungsgedämpfnis kommt. Also es ist wirklich schlimm. Und da muss ich auch was tun. Ich denke, die Industrie muss sich jetzt hier auch darüber im Klaren werden, dass hier unter Umständen ihre komplette Branche versenkt wird, weil man einfach so eine Technologie nicht mehr kaufen kann. Und sie muss auch darüber nachdenken, wie sie in der Lage ist, künftig zumindest und vielleicht eben auch schon für eine gewisse installierte Basis von Technologie Software-Updates zu liefern, um eben dort Schritt zu halten, oder?
Das Problem ist aber, dass wirklich bei vielen Basis-Stationen die Software-Update nicht möglich ist, weil die Software eben im Rom ist. Und es wird keiner herkommen und wird das Rom von so einem Ding auslöten. Da ist billiger irgendwie eine neue Basis-Station.
Vor allen Dingen, die Dinger sind verkauft und die schert sich kein Hersteller mehr.
Genau. Also für Hersteller ist das, glaube ich, eher eine lustige Sache oder eine gute Sache, weil die können neue Basis-Stationen verkaufen und in zwei Jahren sagen, das ist sicher.
Mit sehr guten Verkaufsargumenten. Tja, wenn man jetzt wirklich mit ohne Kabel telefonieren will, aber dann trotzdem ein gewisses Sicherheitsinteresse hat, was ist da so euer Tipp?
Na ja, einmal UMTS scheint noch einigermaßen sicher zu sein. Zumindest bis zur TKÜV, die dann in der Vermittlungsstelle sitzt. Und schnurgebundene Telefone. Man kann auch irgendwie WLAN-Telefone mit WPA2 verwenden.
Ich habe das selber schon seit zwei Jahren daheim. Ich bin noch ein WLAN-Access-Point und ein WLAN-Telefon. Ich würde es nicht meiner Mutter, die geschlossene Packung hingeben, sagen, hier schließt man, richte mal ein. Für den technischen Interessierten ist das durchaus übenziehbar.
Ich meine, es ist halt nichts anderes als DECT. Bei DECT kann man seiner Oma sagen, geh mal in den Saturn, hol dir mal ein Telefon, dann hast du ein schnurloses Telefon.
Genau, da hängen zwei Kabel dran. Das eine passt nur in die Telefonsteckdose rein, passt net in den Strom rein. Das andere passt nur in den Strom, net in die Telefondose rein. Und dann funktioniert das.
Nein, das passt nicht da rein. Ich habe da schon anderes gesehen.
Ja, ich denke, es gibt noch eine interessante Sache.
Habt ihr noch was? Was mich ein bisschen interessiert, ist jetzt wiederum, bei DECT ist jetzt einmal das große Neumachen angesagt. Zumindest, okay, das heißt, am Anfang werden die Leute, vermute ich, einfach mal erstmal ihre Bugs aus ihren Software-Stacks rausfischen, aber irgendwie in einer Form wird es ja dann mal Nachfolger-Standard geben. Da bin ich jetzt, da waren wir mal ein bisschen überlegen, wie könnte der denn aussehen, wenn er toll ist? Und da ist jetzt wiederum die erste Überlegung, okay. So, IPEI über DECT, da gibt es irgendwie inzwischen auch schon so ein paar Überlegungen dazu. Und die zukünftige Basisstation, die wird vielleicht dann doch mehr am Ethernet-Kabel hängen oder am DSL-Modem anstelle von einem Telefonanschluss. Und das könnte eigentlich ein relativ schönes neues System geben. IP über DECT? Ja, die neue DECT-Basis hängt man dann direkt ins IP-Netzwerk dran, die macht dann Voice-over-IP. Weil die vielen neuen Telefonanschlüsse sind eben Voice-over-IP. Und das Telefon, den kann man vielleicht auch gleich mit IP beibringen. Und dann hat man plötzlich IP zu IP auf eine Menge der Telefonanschlüsse. Weil, wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, man tauscht jedes DECT-Telefon in Deutschland gegen so ein Gerät aus, was IP macht, dann könnte man auch mal wiederum so was nachdenken wie Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung und ähnliches. Und das klingt im ersten Moment gar nicht mal so schlecht. Also das Problem ist halt, zurzeit, diese Voice-over-IP-Sachen, die sind noch so ein bisschen fricklich, funktionieren zwar prinzipiell schon, aber sind nicht ganz so fein einzurichten und sind noch ein bisschen so in Kinderschuhen. Allerdings, wenn das in zwei, drei Jahren mal so richtig marktreif ist, also okay, es wird ja schon verkauft, aber so fehlerfrei. Und man hat dann plötzlich ein bisschen zu seiner Basisstation IP und dann auch auf dem Telefon noch mit IP. Und dann kann man halt direkt auf dem Telefon über DECT irgendwie SIP fahren und hat dann vielleicht dort auch noch mal mit Crypto auf dem Link drauf und so. Das könnte eine echt nette Sache werden.
Gut, vielleicht so zum Schluss noch mal ein paar Ressourcen. Habt ihr selber Informationsmaterial auf dem Web oder irgendwo platziert?
detektet.org.
Genau.
Also nicht Detektet, sondern Detektet.
Was wir allen Hörern dieses Podcasts sehr ans Herzen legen.
Was findet man dort?
Da findet man zum einen den Treiber für die Common Air-Karte. Dort findet man eine Implementierung von DSAA.
Sogar mehrere.
Dort findet man, glaube ich, auch unsere Vortragsfolien vom Kongress.
Jawohl, plus ein paar schöne Bilderchen von diesem wunderbaren Saal.
Die Möglichkeit, uns zu kontakten.
Genau.
Eine Mailing-Liste für das Projekt.
Und eben demnächst auch, wenn der DSC fertig ist, die komplette Beschreibung und eine Softwareimplementierung.
Ein Wireshark-Plugin und ein KSMet-Plugin zum Sniffen.
Ja, die Kommandozeilen, User-Space-Utility zum So-Sniffen. Ein paar Skripte, die dann aus den gesnifften Daten bei DECT noch gleich Audio mit draus extrahieren und irgendwie komfortabel in WAF-Files ablegen. Kann man dann auch vielleicht irgendwie, wenn irgendwer will, kann jemand was bauen, dass das dann irgendwie gleich nach MP3 raus exportiert und auf ein iPod syncht oder so.
Also über UserSpace-Entwickler freuen wir uns immer.
Ach so, vielleicht kann ich auch jemand, der hier zuhört, der Problematik annehmen, dass wir derzeit noch White-Band-Codecs haben, die wir nicht dekodiert haben. Also es gibt White-Band, das heißt bessere Sprachqualität. Normalerweise ist der Codec ein G721, respektive G726. ADPCM, das sind 32 Kilobit.
Das klingt erstmal nicht schlecht, aber das ist noch eine CD-Qualität.
Bei ISDN sind es dann auch 64 Kilobit.
Man merkt die Kongressauswirkungen hier.
Bei diesen Next-Generationen haben sie diese White-Band-Codecs eingeführt, damit man eben High-Fidelity-Audio hat.
Was ist das dann, mp4 oder was?
Ja, das weiß ich derzeit nicht genau. Es steht im Standard drin, aber ich habe die Stelle eben noch nicht gelesen bisher.
Dann gibt es dieses frez.org, was wir schon erwähnt haben. Da gibt es so ein Tracksystem und so. Tralala, da kann man sich alles runterladen, um mit der Fritzbox mal herum zu experimentieren, falls man Lust hat, ein DECT-Stack zu schreiben. Da hättet ihr sicherlich großes Interesse an.
Das hätten wir sehr gerne. Und sonst noch auf ebay.de, da kann man sich auch irgendwie nettes Equipment kaufen. Da gibt es zum anderen auch meistens diese PCMC8 gerade irgendwo gerade im Angebot.
Also das ist die Common R, Typ 2.
Genau, ganz wichtig.
Also die Common, sondern C, O, M, N, R.
Was leider passiert ist, ist, dass derjenige, der die Restbestände hat, nachdem er festgestellt hat, oh, die kann man ja nach dem Kongress viel besser verkaufen, die Preise dafür erhöht hat. Also wir haben vor dem Kongress, hatten wir beschlossen, dass man Leuten Bescheid sagen sollte. Da wurden dann entsprechende Restbestände von diesem Hersteller gekauft und eben auf dem Kongress verkauft, für 23 Euro plus irgendwie einen Betrag an den Füllbord. Jedenfalls ist jetzt irgendwie der Preis, glaube ich, auf IPEI anscheinend auf 40 Euro plus Versand gestiegen, weil sie eben festgestellt haben, oh, da ist eine Nachfrage.
Angebote Nachfrage, so funktioniert der Markt. Aber das ist ja auch alles noch zu verkraften.
Ja, aber das ist immer noch so viel bezahlste für eine gute WLAN-Karte auch. Also das ist jetzt nichts, was ich für unverschämt halte. Es ist halt jetzt teurer geworden, aber es ist schon so. Kann man auch tragen. Eine wichtige Sache haben wir noch am Herzen. Und zwar, wir kriegen halt immer wieder Anfrage, sagt man, ich habe doch genau das Sinus-T irgendwas. Sagt man, ist das jetzt sicher? Schlüsselt das wenigstens oder so? Und wir würden ganz gerne so eine kleine Datenbank aufbauen, wo wir sagen können, das Telefon hier, was halt irgendwie die in die Bezeichnung hat, hat anscheinend folgende Software drauf.
So eine Capability-Database, dass man mal weiß, was was macht.
Hat diese RFPI, ist auch wichtig. Also wir wollen eine Datenbank füllen mit RFPI zu Hersteller.
Das ist leider nicht ganz so einfach, weil ich hatte noch mal geschaut, diese Blöcke, die von der Etsy vergeben werden, sind nur 4.096 Geräte, glaube ich, groß. Also sind nur 12 Bit. Das heißt, die Etsy vergibt sogenannte Equipment Manufacturer Codes. Und für 4.096 Geräte gibt es dann immer einen neuen EMC. Das Mapping ist leider nicht so einfach, wobei die Bereiche wahrscheinlich auch zusammen sind. Sie sind leider nicht kontinuierlich.
Na gut, also man muss sozusagen immer mal wieder feststellen, welcher Blog ist das?
Vielleicht gibt es da jemand, der Etsy oder irgendjemand, Etsynas, der uns so eine Datenbank zur Verfügung stellen will. Der gibt es ganz schön auch irgendwo.
Aber ich glaube, da kann man wirklich über das Internet auch relativ schnell fündig werden. Man weiß ja, um welchen Bereich es sich handelt, oder nicht?
Aber jedenfalls, wenn ihr Telefone übrig habt, die ihr nicht mehr braucht, dann geht auf dect.org. Da habe ich unsere Anschriften mit drauf. Und dann könnt ihr die zumindest hinschicken. Und dann werden wir mal zusehen, dass wir die ein bisschen katalogisiert bekommen. Oder wenn ihr sagt, hey, das Projekt finde ich cool und ich kaufe euch irgendwie ein Telefon, dann steht dort auch eine Kontaktadresse, da könnt ihr euch melden. Und dann sagen wir euch halt mal, welche Telefone wir schon haben, welche wir noch nicht haben. Und wir würden uns halt ganz gerne mal so die Standardgeräte, die zurzeit oft verkauft werden, die würden wir uns ganz gerne ansehen.
Habt ihr ein Wiki für so eine Sachen? Habt ihr auch ein Wiki am Start?
Wir haben auf dect.org auch ein Wiki. Das ist aktuell nicht public editable. Aber normalerweise haben wir eine Mailing-Liste, da kann jeder was drauf posten. Das Archiv ist auch online. Und ja, da kann man sich drauf melden und so. Und vielleicht machen wir dann auch irgendwie ein Public Readable. Sorry, das Wiki ist Public Readable, aber nicht Public Writeable.
Also das mit interessanter Hardware, die wir uns zuschicken lassen, das gilt natürlich nicht nur für Telefone. Wir sind auch an allen anderen DECT-Geräten interessiert, die wir irgendwie bekommen können und noch nicht haben.
Ja, also Whistleblower und Funkhacker aller Länder, vereinigt euch, klickt auf dect.org. Da gibt es demnächst noch eine ganze Menge Spaß, habe ich so schwer den Eindruck. Ihr hattet schon eine Menge Spaß, aber ich glaube, hier ist noch Musik drin. Schönes Projekt, bin beeindruckt. Und ja, ich denke, jetzt gibt es noch irgendwie ein letztes Wort, haben wir alles erwähnt. Ich denke, das war jetzt eine sehr umfangreiche Sendung. Ich bedanke mich auf jeden Fall, Andreas, Erik, Ralf. Und ja, das war es, Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nr. 2. Die ganzen Links, die hier genannt wurden und die Begriffe, findet ihr dann hoffentlich mehr oder weniger vollständig in der Beschreibung auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Jetzt muss ich auch nochmal meine Standards runterrasseln. Ich bin immer interessiert an Feedback, also kommentiert, im entsprechenden Blog-Eintrag auf blog.chaosradio.ccc.de oder schickt uns in Ausnahmefällen auch eine Mail, chaosradio.ccc.de. Gerne immer die Web-Kommentare, weil dann können immer auch andere Leute darauf antworten. Das ist eigentlich in der Regel immer sehr viel sinnvoller. Mit CAE geht es hier munter weiter. Es sind einige spannende Themen auf der Liste. Und von daher wird es hier so abwechslungsreich bleiben, wie es jetzt in diesem Podcast war. Ich sage nochmal Danke und wir sagen alle schön Tschüss.